Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Thomas. Logbuch Netzpolitik, Folge Nummer 139. Tim ist verhindert und die Themensuppe kocht über. Deswegen habe ich mir heute den Thomas mal wieder als Gast eingeladen. Thomas Lohninger, bekannt als, ja als was bist du eigentlich bekannt? Als Netzneutralitätsaktivist und als Geschäftsführer des AK Vorrat Österreich. Oder, wenn ich mich nicht täusche?
Genau, ich habe das Hobby zum Beruf gemacht und inzwischen mache ich wirklich Vollzeit-Netzpolitik. Das ist eigentlich ganz schön.
Wie ist es denn bei euch gerade? Ihr hattet ja das Crowdfunding, um das Review der Gesetze, der Überwachungsgesetze in Österreich zu machen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Wie ist denn das überhaupt eigentlich ausgegangen?
Das ist sehr gut ausgegangen. Wir hatten ein Spendenziel von 25.000 Euro, das haben wir auch erreicht. Wir haben dann am Ende 26.000 Euro zusammengesammelt und nochmal so 9.000 Euro von Firmen bekommen. Dafür, dass es Österreich ist, hat es wirklich gut funktioniert. Ich bin jetzt seit einem halben Jahr in dem Job und natürlich ganz viel Vereinsmeierei, Strukturen aufbauen. Aber das Tolle ist, dass wir ein cooles Team sind, wo vor allem auch ein paar extrem fähige Juristen dabei sind. Deswegen geht da eigentlich irrsinnig viel weiter in dieser Überwachungsstaat-Gesamtrechnung, die das eigentlich ist, was wir machen. Wir greifen dieses Konzept auf, was der Deutsche Verfassungsgericht bei der Abschaffung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung mal geprägt hat. Und wenden das mal auf Österreich an. Und schauen uns genau an, welche Gesetze, welche Überwachungstechnik, welche Spielzeuge gibt es da so? Und inwieweit ist das eigentlich noch alles auf dem Boden der Verfassung? Und wie könnte man sowas denn nicht evaluieren?
Das ist sicherlich eine sehr frustrierende Aufgabe. Ich bin froh, dass ihr da ein Funding für bekommen habt. Also vor allem, wenn man sich die Entwicklung der letzten Tage mal wieder anschaut.
Ja, ich mein, teils teils. Also klar, man sieht irgendwie, dass trotz Noden, trotz allem, was wir wissen, geht die Welt immer noch genau in die falsche Richtung. Aber es gibt mir insofern ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass wir sehen, zumindest in unserer Community, gibt es langsam Antworten, wie man vielleicht die Überwachung wieder auf den Boden der Verfassung zurückholen könnte. Und diese Geheimdienste einfangen ist nochmal ein viel größeres Problem. Aber zumindest mal so den Bereich, der im Lichte passiert, auf Basis der Gesetze, dass man da irgendwie Instrumente entwickelt, die die höchstgerichtlichen Urteile auch in Betracht ziehen. Das ist schon irgendwie eine ganz spannende Aufgabe am Puls der Zeit. Und es gibt aber auch lustige Aspekte. Wir kriegen jetzt dann bald Anfang Mai, wir haben ganz viele parlamentarische Anfragen gestellt. Das ist sowas wie eine kleine Anfrage bei euch.
Das dürft ihr einfach machen?
Nein, wir haben uns da zwei Oppositionsparteien dazugeholt, die Grünen und die NEOS. Wir haben einfach so mal an die 500 Fragen geschrieben und die dann über die zwei Parteien eingereicht. Und dann kriegen wir jetzt dann bald die Antworten zurück. Und es gibt sicher viel Sprengstoff, wie das denn so ausschaut, mit Staatstrojaner, IMSI-Catcher, Online-Überwachung, den ganzen hübschen Themen in Österreich.
Wer zu viele Fragen stellt, kriegt ja leider auch dann immer viele unschöne Antworten. Ich glaube, das riecht nach Arbeit.
Oh ja, das Schöne ist, dass es genau während der Republik, wo die Antworten kommen. Das heißt, schöne Doppelbelastung.
Wir bleiben mal direkt bei Fragen, auf die es Antworten gab, die dann gar nicht so schön waren. In Deutschland kocht ja gerade das, was sich jetzt endlich mal als BND-Skandal betittelt hat. Die Geschichte ist eigentlich schon ein bisschen länger. Die Basis dieser Probleme haben wir eigentlich schon hier auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik in den letzten Monaten immer mal wieder besprochen. Aber jetzt kocht da mal endlich so ein Süppchen über. Und es geht langsam mal in Richtung von Verantwortlichkeiten, aus denen man sich nicht mehr so einfach rausreden kann. Aber ich fange mal der Reihe nach an. Die Abhörstation in Bad Eibling, die war ja bei uns auch schon öfter mal Thema. Die war bis 2004 ein US-Stützpunkt, also eine Anlage der USA, unterhalten von der NSA. Und war davor auch schon Teil von Echelon, das heißt der letzte Überwachungsskandal, der irgendwie international diskutiert wurde. Da war sie auch schon daran beteiligt, eine ganz illustre Anlage da, sehr geschichtsträchtig. 2004 wurde sie dann eben an den BND übergeben von der NSA. Da haben sie gesagt, okay, wir ziehen uns jetzt hier raus zurück und ihr dürft diesen Ort, den wir da jetzt geschaffen haben, nutzen. Aber sowas machen die Amerikaner natürlich nicht aus Einsicht oder Großzügigkeit, sondern, wie sich herausstellt, mit klaren Ideen dafür, wie denn dieser Ort genutzt werden soll. Denn Bad Eibling wird auch heute noch als Datenerfassungsstelle der NSA geführt. Das heißt, das ist für sie halt einer der Orte, an denen sie zugreifen. Und der Deal zwischen BND und NSA, wo man hier sagen muss zwischen den beiden Regierungen, denn der BND als solcher darf jetzt nicht Verträge über die Überwachung von Bürgern mit anderen Geheimdiensten eingehen. Das geht also immer über die Regierungen. Der Deal, der da also stattgefunden hat, war, was im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, bezeichnet wurde, als so ein Technik gegen Info-Deal. Denn der BND hatte nicht die schöne Technik, die die NSA schon so großartig entwickelt hatte. Und hat quasi gesagt, lasst uns doch mal eure tollen Gerätschaften auch nutzen, gebt uns doch mal Updates, helft uns doch mal hier auf dem Stand der Technik zu bleiben. Und die NSA hat gesagt, ist prima, aber dafür lasst ihr uns dann bitte auch teilhaben an diesen schönen Informationen, auf die ihr dann zugreift. Und das sah dann in der Realität so aus. Neben Bad Eibling ist eine US-Kaserne. Auf dieser Kaserne hat dann nach dieser Übergabe 2004 die NSA sich ein neues Gebäude eingerichtet, ohne Fenster komplett abgeschirmt, dass da nichts nach draußen dringt. Und dort die Special United States Liaison Activity Germany eingerichtet. SUSLEC oder SASLEC abgekürzt. Und darin dann auch ein Verbindungsbüro unterhalten mit dem Namen JSA, Joint Signal Intelligence Activity. Das heißt, sie hatten sogar ein eigenes Büro, das der Zusammenarbeit zwischen den beiden Diensten verschrieben war. Das wurde erst 2012 geschlossen. Aber so wie es sich jetzt anhört, ist es da eher der Automatisierung zum Opfer gefallen. Denn dort in Bad Eibling scheint sich zu befinden, die Schnittstelle zwischen NSA und BND. Das sieht dann so aus, da wird offenbar ein Kabel rüberführen von diesem schönen abgeschirmten Gebäude in das alte Gebäude, was die NSA nicht mehr haben wollte. Und über diese Schnittstelle werden dann die gesammelten Informationen ausgetauscht, aber eben auch die sogenannten Selektoren automatisch gepullt, die der BND dann in seine Überwachungsanlagen füttert. Selektoren sind dann zum Beispiel IP-Adressen, Telefonnummern, E-Mail-Adressen, URLs oder MAC-Adressen von Rechnern. Man sagt, die möchten wir gerne als Selektoren in diesem System überwachen. Das wird dann vom BND, so wie es hier heißt, ungefähr im Schnitt einmal die Woche werden also neue Selektoren gepullt und in das X-Key-Score-System, was der BND dort unterhält, eingefüttert. Dann führen diese Selektoren zu Ergebnissen. Die Ergebnisse gehen dann eben zurück an die NSA, wie bestellt. Jetzt denkt man, wie viele Selektoren sind das denn wohl? Es sind mehrere hunderttausend bis Millionen Selektoren, die die NSA dem BND überreicht. Dafür gibt es natürlich eine Vereinbarung oder Regeln, wo der BND gesagt hat, okay, diesen Regeln müssen diese Selektoren genügen. Das heißt, die zentrale Regel ist natürlich Personen, Unternehmen und Behörden, die unter den Schutz des Grundgesetzes fallen, nach denen darf nicht gesucht werden. Und gleichzeitig hat sich dieses BND-System natürlich ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Die Datenbank, die dort betrieben wird, nennt sich VERAS für Verkehrsanalysesystem. Und die Quellen, die da reinfüttern, sind dann zum Beispiel die Ergebnisse der Überwachung von PLEZIX oder der unter ICONAL bekannt gewordenen Operation, mit der der Telekom-Schnittpunkt in Frankfurt abgehört wurde. Dann die Satellitenaufklärung, die dort in Bad Eiblingen stattfindet. Dort auf dem Gelände stehen insgesamt neun Radome. Radome sind diese schönen Zelte, also eigentlich sind das Zelte, die einerseits dem Schutz der Anlagen vor Witterungen dienen und natürlich auch dem Sichtschutz, sodass nicht einfach jemand vorbeifährt und Fotos von den Antennen macht, wie das bei euch der Ehrenwälte Erich Möchel gemacht hat. Und dann natürlich auch die Auslandsabgriffe, die der BND so unterhält. Denn der BND überwacht ja auch im Ausland so ähnlich, wie es die NSA eben macht. Und jetzt haben wir ja schon gesagt, es sind also mehrere Hunderttausend bis Millionen Selektoren, die da automatisch in das System eingepflegt werden und automatisch die Ergebnisse zurückliefern. Und bereits 2005 haben dann Mitarbeiter des BND gemerkt, dass da zum Beispiel EADS und Eurocopter mit drin auftauchten. EADS, des Rüstungs- und Weltraumflugunternehmen. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sage, ist EADS auch oder ist das nur Rüstung? So viele Abkürzungen inzwischen, da müssen wir direkt mal schnell googeln.
Ja, es ist vor allem Rüstung, aber auch Luft- und Raumfahrt, sehe ich gerade.
Also die Airbus-Gruppe, alles Mögliche, aber eigentlich natürlich, klar, interessiert die nicht unbedingt. Also mag die natürlich auch interessieren, was Airbus so baut. Vor allem, wenn man sich überlegt, dass da in Kansas und in verschiedenen US-Bundesstaaten mit Boeing ein Konkurrent arbeitet, aber natürlich interessieren die sich da insbesondere auch für die Rüstungssachen. 2005 hat man das zum ersten Mal gemerkt, also direkt ein Jahr nachdem die ganze Sache aufgebaut wurde und, wenn ich freundlich darauf hinweisen darf, vor zehn Jahren. Damals noch unter Kanzler Schröder. Und 2008 gab es dann die erste dokumentierte Meldung ans Kanzleramt, weil ich davon ausgehen würde, dass man das vielleicht auch schon 2005 gemacht hat, aber das ist jetzt momentan nicht Stand der Erkenntnisse. 2008 war dann Kanzlerin Merkel schon im Kanzleramt. Und eine solche Meldung landet dann bei dem Geheimdienstkoordinator, würde man meinen, das war von September 2005 bis Ende 2009. Klaus-Dieter Fritsche, das ist so ein Name, den man sich merken sollte, denn überall, wo es irgendwie nach Überwachungsproblemen und Geheimdienstscheiße stinkt, ist Klaus-Dieter Fritsche nicht weit. Und 2008 war dann der Bundesminister für besondere Aufgaben, umgangssprachlich Kanzleramtsminister, in den ersten drei Viertel des Jahres de Maizière und ab Oktober dann der gute Herr Pofalla. Beide sind ja den Logbuch Netzpolitik-Hörern sicherlich auch in guter Erinnerung. Pofalla war derjenige, der diese Geheimdienstaffäre nach wenigen Tagen für beendet erklärt hat und sich einen schönen Posten bei der Deutschen Bahn kurz darauf angetreten hat. De Maizière ist dem kundigen Hörern und Hörerinnen bekannt als heutiger Innenminister, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe. Das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen blöd, weil, wie gesagt, seit 2008 das Kanzleramt davon Ahnung hat, da waren es immer noch mal fünf Jahre, bis irgendwann Snowden ins Gespräch kam. Und 2008 gab es dann bei einem Review, wie gesagt, wir reden von mehreren hunderttausend bis Millionen Selektoren, die sich also auch theoretisch die ganze Zeit ändern, beziehungsweise praktisch die ganze Zeit ändern und theoretisch vor allem die ganze Zeit ändern können. Und bei diesem Review kam dann heraus, dass es so insgesamt 40.000 kritische Selektoren gab, die dann eben aufgefallen sind. Und es ist aber jetzt unklar, ob diese 40.000 kritischen Selektoren auch tatsächlich im Einsatz waren oder ob die gefiltert wurden. Es gab dann wohl auch automatische Filterversuche. Also man kann natürlich davon ausgehen, dass der BND so viel traue ich denen noch zu. Wenn sie also einmal feststellen, dass da ein Selektor mit dabei war, der den Vereinbarungen nicht genügte, dass sie den dann vielleicht auch in Zukunft automatisch gefiltert haben. Aber allein die Zahl 40.000 sollte ja jedes Vertrauen für eine Zusammenarbeit da in sich zusammenbrechen lassen. Wie gesagt, das war der Kenntnisstand 2008. Dann gab es 2013, nachdem der Snowden über uns alle hereinbrach, noch mal ein Review, wo man dann 2000 weitere problematische Selektoren gefunden hat. Und jetzt ist das natürlich so, der Weg, den die Bundesregierung gerade noch für sich versucht zu finden, um aus dieser Nummer noch mal rauszukommen, ist zu sagen, oh mein Gott, BND, da sind ein paar Sachen nicht in Ordnung gewesen. Das müssen wir jetzt lückenlos aufklären. Aber wie natürlich Beamtenbürokratie funktioniert, Verantwortung wird immer schön schnell nach oben weggereicht. Also wenn jemand über ein Problem stolpert, dann wird das einfach nach oben berichtet. Das ist auch das einzig Sinnvolle, was du in so einer Situation tun kannst. Weil in dem Moment, wo du es nach oben berichtet hast, bist du aus der Verantwortung raus. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wo endet denn jetzt diese Kette der Verantwortung? Es könnte natürlich sein, dass der gute Herr Schindler, dem der BND untersteht, da seiner Verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden ist und gesagt hat, okay, ich verheimliche das, ich reporte das nicht an die nächsthöhere Stelle, aber eben diese Meldung aus 2008 spricht da schon eine andere Sprache. Jetzt könnte es natürlich sein, dass dann der Herr Fritsche oder der Herr Messier, der Messier die Sache irgendwie im Sander haben verlaufen lassen, aber irgendwo dort oben, irgendwo an der Spitze des BND und mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit dann doch eher im Kanzleramt, ist die Verantwortung für diese gesamte Problematik zu suchen. Und ich denke, dass auch da im Kanzleramt, wo die politische Verantwortung dafür sowieso liegt, unabhängig davon, ob jetzt vielleicht ein BND dann Sachen noch verheimlicht hat, wonach es eben im Moment nicht aussieht, dieser Skandal eben auch richtig aufbewahrt ist. Das ist jetzt mal, jetzt wird es so richtig schmackhaft. Jetzt kommen wir endlich mal an den Punkt. Wir haben jetzt schon viele Einzelskandale in Deutschland behandelt in Folgen dieser Snowden-Enthüllungen und der Untersuchungen, die sich dann eben im Bereich der Geheimdienste und dank des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses und den kritischen Fragen der dortigen Abgeordneten ergeben haben. Aber das ist jetzt mal so eine Nummer, wo es danach aussieht, dass sie da nur mit großer Anstrengung ihren Kopf noch mal aus der Schlinge kriegen. Und das sehe ich natürlich durchaus mit einer Genugtuung. Aber es ist natürlich gleichzeitig auch absolut schockierend. Ich schwanke da jetzt so. Ich meine, auf eine gewisse Weise ist wahrscheinlich jemand, der 2015 einen solchen Zusammenhang nicht vermutet hat und entsprechend jetzt noch wirklich überrascht oder schockiert ist, das ist wahrscheinlich schon eher ziemlich naiv. Gleichzeitig ist es wahrscheinlich auch naiv zu hoffen, dass sich jetzt deshalb nochmal irgendwas ändert. Aber wir werden gespannt bleiben dürfen.
Ich meine, korrektiere mich aber, der Bericht kam doch irgendwie von Spiegel, oder? Die haben diese Geschichte nach außen getragen. Ich finde es irgendwie bemerkenswert, dass es hier scheinbar diese Meldung gab. Hier werden Selektoren verwendet, die offensichtlich gegen unsere eigenen Interessen verstoßen und sogar illegal in Deutschland sind. Also die Meldung wurde gemacht. Es ist das Bewusstsein da. Das ist nicht nur ein rein vollautomatisierter Prozess, sondern es hätte die Möglichkeit gegeben, da politisch verantwortungsvoll zu handeln an dieser Stelle. Aber die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass man sich bewusst dazu entschieden hat, das halt runterzuspielen und sozusagen dieser alte Mythos, Enemies, wie sei das nochmal, Freunde spielen ihnen keine Freunde aus oder so. Da merkt man, wie bedeutungslos der eigentlich ist, weil es wird davon ausgegangen, dass man sich irgendwie gegenseitig in dieser Welt versucht, die Geheimnisse abzurängen und auch Wirtschaftsspionage zu betreiben. Und insofern wird es dann auch nochmal ein Stückchen klarer, warum man dann zum Beispiel von so vielen Staaten aus keine Konsequenzen gegenüber den Briten gefordert hat, als klar wurde, dass der dortige Geheimnis GCHQ genauso auch auf Bündnispartner und auch innerhalb der EU scheinbar Dinge getan hat, die man eigentlich so von Partnern nicht erwarten würde.
Ja, also um das kurz zu korrigieren, ich glaube, der ursprüngliche Artikel, in dem diese gesamte Zusammenarbeit, Bad Eibling und so, behandelt wurde, das war ein Artikel in der Süddeutschen Zeitung schon vor mehreren Monaten, wenn nicht sogar schon in einem Jahr. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau, welcher das war. Da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich den noch in den Show Notes identifiziere und verlinke. Diese Ergebnisse, die jetzt diskutiert werden, sind aber eher Ergebnisse, die sich aus der Befragung im Untersuchungsausschuss noch mal ergeben haben. Und die wiederum bezogen sich dann relativ viel auf diesen ursprünglichen Artikel der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Aber natürlich, klar, es wäre halt auch sinnlos. Ich meine, diese ganzen Ausgaben, ja, das ist ja nicht billig, diese ganze Überwachung. Das ist ja teures Equipment. Da wird relativ viel Geld ausgegeben. Und es wäre halt fast schon fahrlässig, so viel Geld auszugeben, ohne sich irgendwelche Gedanken zur Re-Monetarisierung des gesamten Unterfangs zu machen. Und wenn du halt schon irgendwie ein Land vollständig überwachst, dann ist es natürlich naheliegend, da wenigstens irgendwie auch noch ein bisschen Wirtschaftsspionage zu betreiben, um deiner nationalen Wirtschaft irgendwie zumindest ein bisschen zu helfen, um sicherzustellen, dass du da Arbeitsplätze bewahren kannst.
Ja, aber das hat ja auch wieder so ein Grundproblem, das ja auch ein bisschen Selbstverständnis ist, weil, ich meine, EADS ist ein europäisches Unternehmen, das ist nicht nur Deutschland und Frankreich, da sind viele Länder beteiligt, die Niederlande geht stark, und das ist natürlich dann auch ein Vertrauensbruch innerhalb der EU. Ich meine, wie sollte sich jetzt zum Beispiel, wie sollten sich die Niederlande oder Frankreich jetzt korrekterweise verhalten? Das ist ja auch irgendwie eine beschissene Situation, wenn du niemandem mehr trauen kannst.
Das ist der Scheiß mit diesen Geheimdiensten. Also, wie gesagt, es ist offenkundig demokratiefeindlich. Es ist offenkundig schädlich. Und Geheimdienste existieren natürlich zum Schaden anderer Interessen. Und dieser Mythos, dass sie das aber irgendwie auf der Basis einer Verfassung tun, oder mit dem einzigen Ziel des Schutzes, ich glaube, an den kann ja jetzt nun wirklich nicht mehr ernsthaft jemand glauben. Ich weiß, es gibt da so eine kleine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft von Snowden-Truthern, die jetzt auch irgendwie, wo habe ich das denn gelesen? Ich glaube, in der VATS, wo dann wieder stand, ja, und wir haben wieder mal gesehen, eine Massenüberwachung findet nicht statt, denn es sind ja nur irgendwie ein paar Hunderttausend bis Millionen Selektoren, über die die gesamte Kommunikation gecampt wird. Das ist ja noch keine Massenüberwachung. Also ich meine, da sind ein paar Leute, die da aus irgendwelchen Gründen sich das alles nochmal schönreden wollen, aber dass solche Anlagen da irgendwie nennenswert zum, oder mit dem Hauptziel des Schutzes existieren, ist glaube ich eine These, die zunehmend unhaltbar wird. Ich sage nicht, dass sie nicht auch theoretisch zum Schutz betrieben werden, aber die naheliegenden zu erreichenden Ziele mit solchen Anlagen sind eben ganz andere. Und es ist natürlich eine absolute Fahrlässigkeit, wie man sich überhaupt hinstellen kann als Geheimdienst und sagt, okay, wir haben ja so eine Anlage. Wir sind selber nicht in der Lage, so eine Technik zu bauen. Wir möchten aber so eine Technik haben. Und wir gehen dafür das Risiko ein, eben einem fremden Staat, der jetzt nicht dafür bekannt ist, irgendwelche Verfassungen besonders zu achten. Erst recht nicht die von anderen Ländern oder die Interessen von anderen Ländern, denen da irgendwie überhaupt einen Zugriff darauf zu geben, ist ja schon ein Riesenproblem. Im Prinzip hätte man sagen sollen, okay, passt auf, Freunde, wir gucken darauf. Und wenn wir da was finden, dann sagen wir euch schon Bescheid. Ich meine, das wäre jetzt so eine national souveräne Herangehensweise an so eine Zusammenarbeit gewesen. Aber das hat hier auch nicht stattgefunden. Das Ganze geht zurück auf ein Memorandum of Agreement zwischen Michael Hayden, dem damaligen NSA-Chef, und dem damaligen BND-Präsidenten August Hanning, was sie schon im April 2002 unterzeichnet haben. Da haben sie gesagt, wir wollen jetzt mit Bad Eibling nach Taliban und Al-Qaeda-Kämpfern suchen. Und in Krisenregionen Nordafrikas wollen wir natürlich dann auch auf der Landkarte unserer Überwachung halten. Und dann hat eben Hayden gesagt, wir halten uns an deutsches Recht und nutzen diese Station nur für die Bekämpfung des Terrorismus. Und zumindest eins ist klar, dass die Amerikaner eben diesen Vertrag oder dieses Agreement die ganze Zeit systematisch gebrochen haben. Und man weiß doch, wie Dinge laufen. Wir wissen eben seit 2008, dass der BND schon 2005, da hat ja die Anlage ja gerade mal ein Jahr betrieben, schon Grund hatte zum Zweifel daran, dass die Amis sich an die vereinbarten Spielregeln halten. Und seit 2008 spätestens weiß es das Kanzleramt. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, klar, jetzt muss dann wieder alles untersucht. Und es werden und es wird schwierig sein, da die entsprechenden Beweise zu finden, weil Geheimdienste natürlich das Wort Geheimnis groß schreiben und eben auch wissen, wie sie ihre Geheimnisse wahren. Ich glaube, die einzige Hoffnung, die wir da haben, ist eben, dass jeder einzelne Mitarbeiter da auch zumindest darauf geachtet haben, die Verantwortung von sich zu weisen. Und ich kann mir sehr, sehr schwer vorstellen, dass irgendwo auf den unteren Hierarchie-Ebenen irgendjemand gesagt hat, naja, okay, diesen Landesverrat, auf den es ja letztendlich dann hinausläuft, den ziehe ich jetzt einfach mal durch und riskiere damit meinen Job, meine Pensionsansprüche und meine persönliche Freiheit. Wo es sehr viel einfacher ist, da einfach mal eine vorsichtige Meldung nach oben zu geben und damit die Verantwortung vom eigenen Tisch zu haben und weiterhin ein guter Staatsdiener zu sein. Und gleichzeitig machen die ja auch, also das ist ja auch ein, was man schon seit langer Zeit weiß eben über solche staatlichen Hierarchien, dass die Menschen, die da drin dienen, auch wenn sie einmal eben die Verantwortung abgegeben haben, bereit sind, alles Mögliche zu tun. Also das geht ja nicht nur in den Bereichen der Überwachung. Ich muss mich jetzt sehr anstrengen, da keinen Godwin draus zu machen. Deswegen beziehe ich mich jetzt mal auf die als Milgram-Experimente bekannt gewordene Forschung. Wo eben einfach Menschen angewiesen wurden, Leuten in einem anderen Raum, wenn sie Fragen falsch beantwortet haben oder Aufgaben nicht richtig ausgeführt haben, Stromstöße zu verleihen. Das war natürlich gestellt. Also am anderen Ende saß eine Person, die nicht wirklich dann Stromstöße bekommen hat, sondern das war ein Schauspieler, der einen großen Schmerz vorgetäuscht hat. Neben der Versuchsperson stand also ein Versuchsleiter, der sagte, wir haben das ja alles unter Kontrolle, alles richtig, drehen sie mal ruhig hoch. Da hat dann kein Mensch, die ihm eigentlich obliegende Verantwortung, oder nicht kein Mensch, aber nur sehr wenige Menschen, haben die ihnen eigentlich obliegende Verantwortung, da sie an diesem Hebel saßen, dann auch ausgefüllt und gesagt, das tue ich jetzt nicht und handle entgegen der Anweisung. Hierarchische Anweisungen funktionieren sehr gut. Solange man da selber nicht in der Verantwortung steht, oder es für sein eigenes Gewissen die Verantwortung da auf jemand Ärmeren abfälzen kann, und eben auch in dieser Hierarchie, wie sie eben funktioniert, die Verantwortung abfälzen kann, dann tun Menschen solche Dinge. Und ich würde halt in meiner Desillusion einerseits jetzt schon sagen, es wird so gewesen sein, dass ganz oben auch Bescheid wusste. Und gleichzeitig würde ich davon ausgehen, dass heute jetzt auch ganz oben dafür sorgen wird, dass ganz oben niemand zu Schaden kommt. Ich glaube, das worauf es jetzt hinausläuft, ist, dass sie dann den Schindler irgendwie seinen Hut ziehen lassen, dem irgendwie einen Rücktritt nahelegen bei vollen Bezügen und sagen, Kollege, du musst jetzt mal hier einen fürs Team nehmen und einen müssen wir jetzt opfern, damit die Medien Ruhe geben und damit wir diesen Skandal irgendwie ein bisschen abflachen können. Und ich vermute, dass es so laufen wird. Und ich hoffe, dass wir aber jetzt vielleicht ein paar gute investigative Journalisten und ein paar BND-Mitarbeiter mit Restgewissen finden, die diesen Fall jetzt eben auch aufklären. Denn ich persönlich bin mir also relativ sicher, dass die Verantwortung da im Kanzleramt zu suchen ist. Und zwar auch nicht nur bei irgendwelchen Geheimdienstkoordinatoren oder Kanzleramtsministern, sondern dass das eben so etwas findet nicht einfach statt. Das ist, da wussten alle Bescheid. Da wage ich jetzt mal die steile These. Auch wenn ich schon heraus, wenn ich schon prophezeie, dass genau das endgültige offizielle Ergebnis dieser Angelegenheit in Zweifelsfall ein anderes sein wird.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Aber lass uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen bei den Konsequenzen bleiben. Ist es jetzt überhaupt schon gesichert, dass diese Praxis abgestellt ist? Also dass jetzt keine Selektoren mehr von der NSE gepusht werden, die gegen das Grundgesetz oder gegen die Rechtslage verstoßen?
Nein, das ist nicht gesichert. Ich würde natürlich davon ausgehen, dass es zumindest sehr viel weniger sind. So viel billige ich denen schon zu, dass sie jetzt halt andere, also dass sie diese ganzen Selektoren, die ihnen jemals aufgefallen sind, auch entsprechend filtern. Aber es ist auch klar, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da immer noch Selektoren bei sind, die vielleicht gegen deutsches Recht und gegen dieses Memorandum verstoßen, nicht mehr drin sind, sehr gering ist. Denn allein an der Masse der Selektoren und deren Änderungsfrequenz und der Änderungsfrequenz der politischen Weltlage und damit der Änderungsfrequenz der Interessen der NSA, die machen es ja unmöglich, dass du das wirklich ausschließen kannst. Es sei denn, du machst wirklich einen manuellen Review dieser vielen, vielen tausend Selektoren. Und selbst wenn man es jetzt abstellt, ich meine, selbstverständlich wird uns jetzt erzählt werden, dass diese Praxis vollständig abgestellt ist und dass man jetzt Safeguards implementiert hat und hasse nicht gesehen. Es ist einfach schon praktisch, glaube ich, nicht zu bewerkstelligen.
Ja, und vor allem bei dieser Menge an Selektoren ist es ja auch so, dass da überhaupt keine Begründung mitgegeben wird, wieso man jetzt diese MAC-Adresse, diese E-Mail-Adresse überwachen will. Und es gibt vielleicht offensichtliche Fälle, wenn jetzt irgendwo eine EADS-E-Mail-Adresse drin ist oder eine bekannte Telefonnummer. Aber es gibt sicherlich genügend Selektoren, die man verwenden könnte, wo es nicht offensichtlich ist, wer denn das eigentliche Ziel davon ist. Das kann irgendein privates iPad sein oder irgendein Familiengerät. Da fällt der NSE sicherlich genügend ein, wie man über den Kontext genügend herausfindet, was sonst vielleicht offensichtlich nicht durchgehen würde.
Richtig.
Deswegen ist es, glaube ich, schon auch so eine der Forderungen, die man hier stellen könnte, dass man diese Selektoren zumindest im Nachhinein öffentlich macht. Wenn die Verfahren abgeschlossen sind, all diese Gefahren oder Verdachtsmomente, die ja so eine Überwachung im besten Fall anlassbezogen auslösen, sind ja auch irgendwann mal abgestellt. Und dann müsste es irgendeine Form von öffentlicher Kontrolle geben, um da zumindest auch mal ein bisschen einen Checks and Balance im Nachhinein zu entwickeln, dass man wenigstens weiß, was tut diese Behörde hier eigentlich. Ich glaube, ohne Transparenz kommen wir da nie wieder raus.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das nie geschehen wird. Also unter der Annahme, dass sie da wirklich Terroristen überwachen, könnten sie ja, und das ist ja auch das, was an dieser Geheimdienstaffäre den Geheimdiensten so starke Kopfschmerzen bereitet, dass was sie wirklich ärgert, ist, dass ihre Fähigkeiten bekannt werden. Denn das führt natürlich dazu, dass Personen, nicht unbedingt nur Terroristen und Mörder, sondern auch ganz normale Bevölkerung, sich für Maßnahmen interessieren, dem zu entgehen und sich davor zu schützen. Und du möchtest ja als Geheimdienst eigentlich immer chronisch unterschätzt werden. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ich fand das sehr schön. FIFA hat das in irgendeiner Alternativlos-Folge mal gesagt. Der beste Geheimdienst der Welt ist der dänische, denn von dem hat noch nie einer was gehört. Und dem Land geht's super. Du möchtest ja als Geheimdienst eben geheim operieren. Und das ist natürlich für die sehr ungünstig, wenn öffentlich bekannt wird, welche Fähigkeiten sie haben. Und es ist für sie sehr günstig, wenn einfach niemand weiß, was sie tun.
Für Geheimdienste ist das sicherlich die beste Operationsbedingung, aber für uns als Demokratie ist das leider nicht so. Und ich glaube, dass wir den Behörden nur noch Herr werden können, wenn wir sie in die Öffentlichkeit zerren. Natürlich kann dann Desinformation erst recht wieder oder irgendein Theater die Konsequenz sein. Und am Ende muss man dann aber trotzdem auch wieder darauf vertrauen, dass einzelne Leute moralisch handeln. Also es bleibt ja auch ein bisschen Resthoffnung, dass diese Information jetzt über den aktuellen Skandal auch an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist, weil irgendjemand nicht die Klappe gehalten hat, sondern gesehen hat, dass es hier ein öffentliches Korrektiv braucht.
Ja, oder halt auch die vollständige Abschaffung solcher Institutionen.
Ja, aber wie würdest du das kontrollieren, wenn du nicht überprüfst, ob ein Geheimnis wirklich abgeschafft ist?
Ja, ja, wir machen jetzt zu. Das wäre vielleicht gar nicht so blöd, wenn die jetzt sagen, ja, ja, okay, wir lösen den gesamten BND auf. Gründenhalten was anderes, ein Kegelklub oder so. Und der macht halt dann weiter. Ja, ich denke halt, die Offenlegung dieser Tätigkeiten, ich bin ja eigentlich bei dir, es steht der Nachweis aus, dass die Offenlegung dieser Tätigkeiten zu irgendeinem Nachteil geführt hätte, für uns. Also das hat sicherlich zu Nachteilen für den Geheimdienst geführt. Aber ich sehe jetzt gerade nicht, wie das für mich persönlich als Bürger dieses Landes oder als Bürger Europas zu einem Nachteil geführt hätte. Insofern ist dein Argument da schon richtig so. Das hat uns irgendwie nichts gebracht. Und das hat uns irgendwie geschadet. Und wir möchten vielleicht lieber, dass man das massiv ausleuchtet, vielleicht sogar mit Transparenzauflagen versieht. Man könnte sich auch so etwas vorstellen, dass man sagt, nach so und so vielen Jahren wird das alles offengelegt, und zwar schonungslos. Aber dann werden die dir auch sagen, ja, wir können das noch nicht mal in Echtzeit diese Millionen oder Hunderttausende Selektoren kontrollieren. Wie sollen wir dann die sicherlich weit über eine Million Selektoren, die sich über die Jahre angesammelt haben, darauf kontrollieren, ob sie uns jetzt in ihrer Veröffentlichung noch mal scharen? Also ich glaube, solange man überhaupt anerkennt, dass es legitime Gründe für Geheimdienste gibt, kommst du immer wieder an diesen Punkt, dass du sagst, sie müssen im Geheimen operieren und deswegen müssen wir ihnen vertrauen. Und das konnte man vielleicht bis vor ein paar Jahren mit einem mulmigen Gefühl tatsächlich auch so noch vertreten. Aber heute ist das, glaube ich, ein Argument, für das man nur noch relativ wenig belastbare empirische Argumente findet.
Das glaube ich auch. Dieses Grundvertrauen, das ist eigentlich weg. Die Frage ist nur so, diese zwei diffusen Gefühle, die hier miteinander konkurrieren, sind ebenso diese Angst davor vor dem unbekannten Feind, vor dem Terrorismus, vor den Extremisten. Das ist ja irgendwie, was noch die Berechtigung schürt davor. Ich glaube, dass in den Köpfen der meisten Menschen einfach diese Kollateralschäden hingenommen werden, unter Anführungszeichen, weil man sich ansonsten noch viel mehr zu dem Unbekannten ausgesetzt fühlt. Ich glaube, hier braucht es vielleicht auch eine andere Reaktion auf Terroranschläge, dass wir uns da nicht in unseren Grundfesten jedes Mal so erschüttert fühlen. Wenn wir zurückdenken an Paris und Charlie Hebdo, natürlich sind unserer demokratischen Grundwerte genau das, was hier im Ziel dieses Angriffes stand. Aber kein Terroranschlag der Welt hat die Macht unsere demokratische Grundordnung umzustürzen. Das tun wir im Nachgang dieses Angriffes für die Terroristen. Würden wir das erkennen, dann hätten wir vielleicht auch eine Mehrheit in einer Demokratie, um anders mit diesen Geheimdiensten umzugehen und da halt einfach eine Verhältnismäßigkeit einzufordern. Es sagt ja niemand, dass man sie wirklich abschaffen will. Sondern es braucht halt einfach eine demokratische Kontrolle, eine nachgelagerte Transparenz und Konsequenzen auch auf personeller und funktionaler Ebene, wenn dieses System Scheiße baut. Deswegen ist so ein Skandal wie jetzt gerade auch etwas, was man genau unter die Lupe nehmen muss. Also auch wenn das nur ein Bauernopfer ist, dass der Chef des BND es an Not nehmen muss, trotzdem muss da irgendwas passieren. Weil ansonsten, das wäre dann wirklich das Worst-Case-Szenario, wenn es überhaupt keine Konsequenzen gibt. Zumindest müsste dann eigentlich noch irgendwo mal pro forma jemand im Kanzleramt zumindest eine Rüge bekommen. Ich weiß, das sind jetzt keine wirklich guten Anforderungen, die ich stelle. Aber ich denke schon, auch in der Symbolebene, wenn du damit durchkommst, mit allen durchkommst, was du machst, was ist das für ein Signal in so eine Organisation hinein? Ich meine, das sind die Leute, die an den Terminals sitzen und vor Ex-Ki-Score ihre was auch immer für Menschen im Nahverhältnis dann dort eingeben, potenziell. Die Fälle kennt man ja aus der NSA. Also irgendwo, ohne Verantwortung und Übersicht, glaube ich, haben wir da wirklich ein Problem.
Ärgerlicherweise habe ich aber so das Gefühl, ich habe das ja schon mal, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, es war vielleicht sogar die Sendung, die wir live beim 31C3 aufgenommen haben, wo ich so die Sorge geäußert habe, dass dieser Skandal irgendwann oder diese Aufklärung irgendwann mal in die Geschichte eingehen wird, als etwas, das dann da diskutiert wurde und dass die Menschen damals schockiert waren, aber das, was wir jetzt geklärt haben. Dass am Ende dieser gesamten Aufklärung, dieser gesamten Skandale, die meines Erachtens falsche, aber vielleicht dann doch von der Mehrheit der Menschen irgendwie akzeptierte Schlussfolgerungen steht, dass das eben so sein muss. Das wäre wirklich meine große Sorge.
Es ist immer die Frage, wie geht denn die Geschichte weiter? Ich weiß nicht, ob man diese Analogie wirklich so sauber ziehen kann, aber spätestens dann, wenn ein System ins Totalitäre abgeleitet und seine Macht wirklich augenscheinlich mit Menschenrechtsverletzungen missbraucht, dann gibt es meistens so einen gewissen Backlash. Vielleicht muss so ein Geheimdienstsystem mal wirklich massiv auch missbraucht werden. Ich meine, da könnte man auch argumentieren, in Iran hatten wir so etwas in der Grünen Revolution, in Ansätzen zumindest, wo auch Leute einfach verschwanden aufgrund von ihrer Internetaktivität, weil sie sich da auf Facebook einen Protest angeschlossen haben, ohne Verfahren, ohne das Angehörige erfahren, erfuhren, was mit denen dann los war. Ich glaube schon, man braucht diese Beispiele, dass man dann auf die realen Gefahren von solchen unkontrollierten Behörden hinweisen kann. Ich habe auch eine große Einsicht, die wir da von unseren Politikern fordern, keine Frage.
Na ja, man merkt, wir sind da jetzt, ich glaube auch so ein bisschen, ich bin mal gespannt. Ich hoffe, dass da jetzt noch ein paar Köpfe rollen. Und ich hoffe, dass die öffentliche Debatte da jetzt noch mal wirklich auch an Fahrt gewinnt.
Ist das eigentlich in diesem Geheimdienst, NSC-Untersuchungsausschuss auch so, dass der Vorschläge macht, wie man das Ganze reparieren könnte, das System? Also gibt es da am Ende irgendwie so einen Forderungskatalog, was jetzt als Reform kommen muss, mit dem ihr dann in den Wahlkampf ziehen könnt?
Das kann ich dir noch nicht mal genau sagen. Also ein Untersuchungsausschuss hat ja in der Regel, legt er am Ende einen Untersuchungsbericht vor. Und aus diesem Untersuchungsbericht leiten sich natürlich dann entsprechende politische Forderungen ab. Aber wirklich da, also die Hauptarbeit liegt auf jeden Fall in dem Aufklären. Und was sie halt heute machen, das ist so ein interessantes Beweisantrag oder so was. Also das ist deren Ermittlungsinstrument. Ich muss mal ganz kurz sagen, ja, ich glaube, das war der Begriff, den ich da so komisch fand, aber das scheint der zu sein. Genau, also die Mitglieder in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss stellen also Beweisanträge. Und diese Beweisanträge sind dann eben, die lenken die Ermittlungen dieses Untersuchungsausschusses. Und ja, am Ende stehen da Berichte. Ich meine, wir haben ja in Deutschland Untersuchungsausschüsse zu allmöglichen Quatsch, ja. Irgendwie diese Flughafenruine, die wir uns da außerhalb von Berlin irgendwie hingestellt haben, ja. Das ist auch ein Untersuchungsausschuss. Die müssen dann am Ende, die sollen dann rausfinden, was ist da schiefgelaufen, wer ist dafür verantwortlich. Und genauso soll das jetzt in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss auch sein. Ich bin mir auch sicher, dass der inzwischen, wir haben ihn ja auch streckenweise hier auch gerne mal belächelt, aber inzwischen ist dieser Untersuchungsausschuss, glaube ich, einigen Leuten ein ziemlicher Dorn im Auge. Und ich glaube, die Konsequenzen, die dann aus der Untersuchung gezogen werden, die ergeben sich dann eher aus dem öffentlichen Diskurs und aus dem Handel einer Regierung, die sich eventuell dann eben auf Empfehlungen eines Berichtes oder so berufen mag. Aber grundsätzlich ist es jetzt nicht die Aufgabe des NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses, das Problem zu lösen, sondern das Problem erst mal überhaupt vollständig zu untersuchen. Und irgendwie sieht es nicht so aus, als wären die ja irgendwie in der Nähe des Endes angekommen.
Also meine Hoffnung ist halt so ein bisschen, dass man das zum Wahlkampf-Thema machen kann. Und dass es vor allem für Oppositionsparteien Profilierungsmöglichkeiten bietet, damit eine Forderungsliste, die irgendwie auch abgesegnet ist, die Sinn macht und nicht nur mascarade ist, in den Wahlkampf zu ziehen. Weil ich glaube, da gibt es schon durchaus Potenzial in der Bevölkerung, dass man irgendwie zumindest mal irgendwas tut.
Du, meine Hoffnung wäre, dass morgen die Neuwahlen angekündigt werden, weil die gesamte Führungsregie ihren Hut nehmen muss. Nur mit den Oppositionsparteien, die eine Chance auf Regierungsbeteiligung haben, ist das ja in Deutschland auch so ein Problem. Wir haben ja hier so eine Partei, die SPD heißt, und die da einen Begriff besetzt, der vielleicht heute eigentlich noch von vielen Leuten oppositionell gesehen wird. Aber hoffen wir mal, dass wir nächste Woche Freudiges zu berichten haben und vielleicht erste Köpfe gerollt sind, dass wir der Hörerschaft eine fröhlichere, hoffnungsvollere Sicht auf diese Dinge geben können.
Das wäre doch schön. Nach unserer extrem deprimierenden 31C3-Sendung können wir dann eine total euphorische Republika-Livesession machen für Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Nee, die fällt aus. Ich geh nicht zur Republika. Ich bin verhindert. Ich hätte da leider nicht hingehen können. Aber wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten Thema. Das nächste ist ein kurzes Thema. Was steht quasi auf der To-Do-Liste der Bürgerrechtsanwälte in Deutschland und Bürgerrechtsvereine? Wir haben jetzt erst vor kurzem die Vorratsdatenspeicherung noch mal draufgeschrieben bekommen fürs Jahr 2015. Da wird es also auch wieder eine alle möglichen Klagen, Verfassungsbeschwerden und so weiter geben müssen. Man zwingt uns dazu. Dann hat Holger Münch, der BKA-Chef, Nachfolger von Herrn Zierke, im Spiegel-Interview angekündigt, die Quellen-TKÜ, also der Staatstrojaner des BKA, wird entwickelt und wir sind da guter Dinge, dass wir im Herbst dieses Jahres einsatzbereit sind und dieses Produkt dann auch den Landeskriminalämtern möglicherweise gegen Entgelt zur Verfügung stellen können. Also sowas wie Staatstrojaner as a Service. Und das ist es eigentlich auch schon. Also er hat dann in einem Interview noch gesagt, so ja, wir haben ja ein Problem hier mit der Bandenkriminalität oder der organisierten Kriminalität, denn da gibt es ja Wohnungseinbrüche und Ladendiebstähle, wo gezielt hochwertige Güter gestohlen werden. Und die Täter sind in verschiedenen Bundesländern aktiv. Und das erschwert natürlich dann die Arbeit der LKA. Deswegen ist das eine BKA-Angelegenheit. Und deswegen möchten wir dann die Bandenmitglieder, deren Rechner infizieren und Internettelefonie, Messengerdienste und E-Mail-Verkehr protokollieren. Um das nochmal kurz in den Rahmen zu setzen, weil wir einige Zeit nicht mehr über Staatstrojaner gesprochen haben und die Hörerzahlen von Logbuch Netzpolitik ja sowieso einem Städten exponentiellen Wachstum unterliegen, sodass wir auch immer sehr viele Neuhörer und Hörerinnen begrüßen. Vielleicht nochmal das Problem bei der Quellen-TKÜ und den Staatstrojanern kurz erläutert. Das Problem, was man angehen möchte, ist, dass das Bandenmitglied, der gemeine Kriminelle, schreibt eine E-Mail an seinen Kumpel, mit dem er dann irgendwie einen Einbruch plant, in der sie diesen Einbruch planen, weil er immer noch nicht genug über den Überwachungsstaat und die Fähigkeiten der Ermittlungsbehörden gelernt hat und meint, sich deshalb über E-Mails oder WhatsApp-Nachrichten oder Skype-Gespräche in seinem konspirativen Vorgehen mitteilen zu müssen. Und nutzt zu seinem eigenen Schutz ein Verschlüsselungsverfahren, also etwas, wo man mit einer normalen Quellen-TKÜ also nicht drankommt, denn die Aufzeichnung umfasst dann nur die Aufzeichnung des verschlüsselten Austausches, aber natürlich nicht des Inhalts, der verschlüsselt ist. Und für dieses technische Problem sucht man also die Lösung, nämlich das Endgerät, mit dem diese Kommunikation stattfindet, zum Zeitpunkt, zu dem die Kommunikation stattfindet, infiziert zu haben, um somit als Trojaner den Nutzer überwachen zu können, während die Kommunikation stattfindet. Das heißt, wir beide nehmen jetzt diese Sendung über Skype auf und planen ja auch hier weiter unsere kriminellen Machenschaften in einer Verbindung, die im Zweifelsfall so verschlüsselt ist, dass zumindest einfache Ermittlungsbehörden da nicht drankommen. Das heißt, zu diesem Zwecke wird mir ein Trojaner untergejubelt und auch dir, oder mir reicht eigentlich, der dann eben meine Stimme direkt am Mikrofon abgreift und sich, so war es glaube ich, bei dem alten Trojaner der Fall, als Skype-Plugin positioniert, um dann eben dieses Gespräch aufzuzeichnen. Ähnliches eben, wenn ich eine E-Mail schreibe oder was auch immer. Und natürlich auch bei Mobiltelefonen. Und jetzt kommt der alte Staatstrojaner, der eben vom CCC vor einigen Jahren analysiert wurde und als den Vorgaben oder den strengen Anforderungen nicht entsprechend abgeurteilt wurde. Der hat das Ziel erreicht, indem er einfach Screenshots gemacht hat. Du bist ja in der Herausforderung, deine Zielperson nutzt jetzt was weiß ich. Vielleicht nutzt sie einen E-Mail-Client auf ihrem Computer, vielleicht nutzt sie aber auch ein Web-Interface und schreibt dann irgendwie verschlüsselt auf die eine oder auf die andere Weise. Das heißt, du müsstest alle diese Arten irgendwie infiltrieren können. Und das Einfachste, was du natürlich machen kannst, ist, du wirfst einfach einen Keylogger mit rein und zeichnest alle Tastatureingaben auf. Das ist aber eben nach höchstrichterlicher Rechtsprechung geht zu weit, weil du damit eben dann auch alle anderen Eingaben, also auch die private Nachricht an Omi und die Passwörter, die die Person so mit eingibt, mit aufzeichnest. Und damit eben unverhältnismäßig weit in die Privatsphäre dieser Person eindringst. Der alte Staatstrojaner hat das auch einfach mit Screenshots gemacht. Das heißt, er hat einfach regelmäßig den Bildschirm fotografiert. Und dann eben auch natürlich zu Zeitpunkten, wo die Zielperson vielleicht auch gerade mit etwas ganz anderem beschäftigt war. Und es ist nach meiner Auffassung, wenn vielleicht auch, selbst wenn man der Ansicht wäre, dass es in Ordnung ist, die Integrität des informationsverarbeitenden Systems des Bürgers zu verletzen, um in bestimmten Anwendungsfällen eben Kommunikation abhören zu können, was man eben im Rahmen einer normalen Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachungsanordnung eben auch darf. Die dürfen ja mein Telefon abhören, wenn sie dafür einen richterlichen Beschluss haben. Selbst wenn man also sagt, okay, ich halte es für gerechtfertigt, dass es eben auch bei E-Mails oder bei Ende-zu-Ende-verschlüsselten E-Mails möglich ist, dies zu tun, dann gibt es eine technische Hürde, dass ich als Experte, ich bin ja Experte, der an sich bin, dass es nicht möglich ist, etwas so zu bauen, dass es nur dies tut und damit nicht gleichzeitig sich als Beweismittel untauglich erweist. Also ich glaube, es ist grundsätzlich technisch nicht möglich, einen Staatstrojaner zu bauen oder überhaupt eine Malware zu entwickeln, die den höchstrichterlichen Anforderungen an eine Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung genügt.
Ich mache hier kurz irgendwie den Realitätscheck mit Österreich, weil ich finde es wahnsinnig toll, dass ihr auf dieser Ebene seid, wo ihr die Kredit von informationstechnischen Systemen mitbedenkt in der höchstgerichtlichen Rechtsprechung, die dann technisch umgesetzt werden soll. Es gibt in Österreich genau einen Urteil zum Staatstrojaner, das sagt, das ist ja so etwas wie, wenn du eine Kamera hinter deinem Rechner platzierst, und insofern ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Dieses Urteil ist aufgrund einer alten Rechtsordnung, das ist zwar vom Obersten Gerichtshof gefällt worden, bei dem Fall Mohamed M., sogenannten Kinderzimmerterroristen in Österreich. Ich glaube, 2008 war das. Und die Rechtsordnung, auf der das damals gesprochen wurde, gibt es gar nicht. Aber solche Fragen sind dort überhaupt nicht diskutiert worden. Dass man da irgendwie in ein System eingreift, dass man ja gleichzeitig beobachtet und danach als Beweis verwerten will, so weit sind die Richter gar nicht gegangen damals. Wir haben aber auch irgendwie die komische Grausituation, dass wir ja auch aufgrund des Trojaners, den der ZTC damals ja gefunden hat in Bayern, da wissen wir ja, dass Österreich auch Kunde von dieser Firma war. Aber die Rechtsgrundlage ist eben sehr strittig in Österreich. Und das ist auch so eins der Themen, zu dem wir eben diese parlamentarischen Anfragen gestellt haben. Wir haben insgesamt sechs parlamentarische Anfragen zum Thema Staatstrojaner, sehe ich gerade. Also das wird auch spannend. Wie ist es nämlich überhaupt in Österreich? Auch da ist es schon irgendwie unklar. Die ganze Debatte ist noch eher in den Kinderschuhen.
Vielleicht kurz so sagen, wie das bei uns dazu kam, dass wir dieses Grundrecht auf Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme haben. Das haben wir in Deutschland seit 2008 und zwar in einem Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts bekommen. Und dieses ging einher mit dem Ergebnis mehrerer Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen die Vorschriften im Verfassungsschutz. Ich will immer Verfassungsschutz sagen, das heißt Verfassungsschutzgesetz von Nordrhein-Westfalen zur Online-Durchsuchung. Die Quellen-TKÜ, die Online-Durchsuchung sollte da eben ermöglicht werden. Bei der Online-Durchsuchung geht es sogar noch weiter, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, wo man eben sagt, okay, da reden wir gar nicht von einer wirklichen Quellen-TKÜ, sondern da reden wir einfach davon, alles klar, wir wollen gucken, was auf dem Computer ist. Bei der Online-Durchsuchung, das ist die Treine, da wollte man entfernte PCs auf verfahrensrelevante Inhalte hin durchsuchen. Ohne tatsächlich am Standort des Gerätes anwesend zu sein. Also da ging es darum, wir wollen einfach mal Vollzugriff auf deinen Computer haben. Und da wurde also gesagt, naja, das dürfen wir ja, wir können ja auch in deine Wohnung gehen und sie durchsuchen. Und so wollen wir jetzt eben auch deinen Computer durchsuchen. Aber natürlich geht es da ja um einen ganz anderen Sachverhalt. Ich meine, die Polizei kann, wenn sie das von einem Richter genehmigt bekommt, natürlich auch hier in meine Wohnung gehen. Und ich muss sie dann reinlassen, dann können sie das hier durchsuchen. Aber das bekomme ich ja auch mit. Da kann ich ja irgendwie sehen, kann ich irgendwie Widerspruch einlegen, was ich auf jeden Fall machen werde. Also kommt gar nicht erst auf die Idee. Und wenn sie aber jetzt irgendwie einfach meinen, im Verdachtsfall einfach mal meinen Computer trojanisieren, sich darauf umschauen und dann sagen, naja, okay, ist in Ordnung. Der Neumann ist gar nicht so gefährlich, wie er immer tut. Dann ist das eben eine Verletzung meiner intimsten Privatsphäre, die da in keiner Form gerechtfertigt ist. Und das ging eben auch damit aus dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde hervor, dass man eben gesagt hat, okay, das geht nicht. Wir haben ein Grundrecht auf die Gewährleistung der Vertraulichkeit und Integrität unserer informationstechnischen Systeme. Und Verletzungen dieses Grundrechts müssen eben sehr enge Bedingungen erfüllen. Und daher kam dann eben nachher diese Idee der Quellen TKÜ, also zu sagen, okay, was wir nicht machen, wir schieben nicht die Wohnungsdurchsuchung in die digitale Sphäre, aber wir schieben die Telekommunikationsüberwachung in die digitale Sphäre und nennen das Ganze Quellen der Telekommunikationsüberwachung, weil wir eben direkt an der Quelle ansetzen, wo es stattfindet. Und auch da, also das ist glaube ich sehr klar, sobald sie sich trauen, wieder irgendwo einen Staatstrojaner einzusetzen, hoffen wir natürlich, dass wir wieder einen so mutigen Anwalt finden, der uns dann darüber in Kenntnis setzt als CCC, wenn der Verdacht im Raume steht, dass sein Mandant ein Opfer dieses Trojaners geworden ist und freuen uns dann auch, diesen einer ausgehenden, unabhängigen, kostenlosen technischen Prüfung zu unterziehen, damit jetzt schon der Aufruf uns da möglichst früh als Sachverständige mit einzubeziehen, um dann eben natürlich auch dagegen hoffentlich wieder erfolgreich vorgehen zu können.
Ja, ich glaube, den CTC als Sachverständigen zu haben, das kann man sich nur wünschen.
Ach, das ist so schön, dass du das sagst, Thomas. Weil ich war doch letzte Woche wieder Sachverständig. Das ist ein anderes Thema, das haben wir ja auch schon behandelt, war ganz nett. Ich war im Innenausschuss mit Herrn Bosbach, da gibt es auch eine Aufzeichnung von, kann ich auch nochmal verlinken.
Ja, ich habe in das Video reingeschaut. Da musst du nochmal mehr erzählen, aber wir sind jetzt eh schon irgendwie in der Zeit.
Ja, wir sind weit drin und wir wollen uns ja auch dem neuen polizeilichen Staatsschutzgesetz in Österreich widmen. Was haben wir denn da Schönes auf euch zu kommen?
Ja, damit habe ich irgendwie die letzten Wochen verbracht. Also fangen wir beim Anfang an. Also irgendwie vor der Sommerpause letztes Jahr gab es die ersten Regungen, dass in Österreich das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung, kurz BVT, reformiert werden soll wegen den ganzen neuen Terrorbedrohungen und ISIS und Foreignfighter und überhaupt. Und wir brauchen ja viel mehr Terrorprävention in Österreich. Und die armen Behörden haben halt überhaupt keine Überwachungsbefugnisse. Die müssen wir endlich aufrüsten. Und da gab es irgendwie einen parlamentarischen Prozess, der anfangs sogar gar nicht so schlecht aussah, aber dann am Ende irgendwie hart rechts abgebogen ist. Und da wurde jetzt eben vor einigen Wochen ein Gesetz vorgelegt, das überhaupt nichts mit dem vorherigen Prozess zu tun hat. Und in dem wird wirklich eine ganz neue Qualität an Überwachung in Österreich etabliert. Da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen. Also dieses Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung und auch seine Landesämter, das ist eine normale Polizeibehörde, die dem Innenministerium unterstellt ist. Die bekommt aber mit dieser Reform fast nachrichtendienstliche Befugnisse, was Überwachung angeht. Und das begründet sich damit, dass es hier einen ganz neuen Tatbestand gibt, der geschaffen wird. Der nennt sich verfassungsgefährdender Angriff. Das sind grob so 40 Straftatbestände von Mords, kriminelle Vereinigungen, aber auch so etwas wie Störung einer Veranstaltung. Man denkt also irgendwie an die Pegida-Demonstrationen oder hier in Österreich sehr beliebt die Akademiker-Bal oder No WKR Demos, wo sich irgendwie die Rechte Europas in der Hofburg in Wien trifft. Da ist immer sehr schön Straßenschlacht im Vergleich zu eurer 1. Mai, glaube ich, trifft das ganz gut. Sowas wäre ein verfassungsgefährdender Angriff, weil man damit eine Veranstaltung stört, die vor allem inzwischen auch unter der Schirmherrschaft der FPÖ steht, also einer gewählten Partei, die im Nationalrat ist in Österreich. Und die neue Qualität ist nicht nur, dass hier irgendwie eine Palette von 40 Straftatbeständen auf einmal zum Terrorismus gemacht wird, wenn sie aus, Zitat, religiös oder weltanschaulichen Motivationen begangen wird. Was auch immer das heißt. Also sobald du irgendetwas tust aus religiösen oder weltanschaulichen Motivationen, hast du auf einmal einen viel höheren Strafrahmen bis zum Terrorismusbereich und eben auch mit einer massiven Überwachungspalette konfrontiert, weil dann fällst du in den Aufgabenbereich dieses neuen reformierten BVTs dieses Bundesamtes. Und es ist aber nicht nur solche Straftaten, wie eben die Störung einer Veranstaltung von Nazis, die darunter fallen, sondern auch die Bewertung der Wahrscheinlichkeit eines solchen Angriffes ist ausreichender Grund für diese Behörde, um die volle Palette an verdeckten und unverdeckten Überwachungsmethoden gegen eine Person oder Personengruppen einzusetzen. Das Ganze ist gepaart mit der Einführung von V-Leuten, also bezahlten Spitzeln. Die gab es vorher in Österreich auch nicht. Die werden hier mit dieser Reform auch gleich mitgeschaffen. Mit überhaupt keiner Sensitivität oder Lehre aus den Erfahrungen aus Deutschland, von dem NSU-Debakel. Hier ist einfach die Möglichkeit geschaffen worden, man versucht jetzt irgendwie das noch mit Richtervorbehalt abzuschwächen. Aber das ändert nichts daran. Das ist im Grunde so ähnlich, wie das, was wir vorher gerade beschrieben haben, mit dem Staatstrojaner. Wenn ich irgendjemanden einschleuse in eine Organisation, und der ist vom Staat bezahlt, um dort Dinge zu tun, habe ich halt immer die Gefahr, dass der dann natürlich auch diese Organisation in eine gewisse Richtung leiten kann. Das ist nur so einer dieser Punkte. Es gibt eine massive Speicherfrist in dieser Reform. Also alle Daten, die hier gesammelt werden, und das sind nicht nur jede Art von Betriebsdaten, Standortdaten, die bei einem ISP herumliegen. Das sind genauso auch Inhaltsauskünfte von mehr oder weniger jedem Server, der in Österreich steht. Auskünfte von allen Behörden und allen anderen Datenbanken, die es in öffentlicher oder privater Hand gibt. Auskünfte über jede Art von Videoaufzeichnung, Tonaufzeichnung, die im privaten Bereich oder im öffentlichen vorhanden ist. Und all das darf für fünf Jahre lang gespeichert werden. Beliebig ausgewertet. Und es gibt einen protokollierten Zugriff. Also wer auf diese Daten zugreift, der muss sich da irgendwie eintragen in ein Protokoll. Aber das nur drei Jahre lang. Die letzten zwei Jahre sind die dann vogelfrei. Und das darf jeder damit machen, was er will. An sich lässt sich festhalten, überall da, wo so in der alten Rechtsordnung ein Richter oder ein Staatsanwalt notwendig war für eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, da braucht es jetzt nur noch den sogenannten Rechtsschutzbeauftragten im Innenministerium. Das ist ein Beamter im Innenministerium, der ist auf dem Papier frei und nicht weisungsgebunden. In Wirklichkeit kann man das durchaus anzweifeln. Das ist eine Person, der noch irgendwie so drei, vier Stellen, aber davon nicht alle voll unterstellt sind. Der ist für den gesamten Rechtsschutz zuständig von der gesamten Polizei und muss da mehr oder weniger im Personalunion alles abnicken und ist die einzige Stelle, die Nein sagen kann, zu irgendeiner Anordnung etwas zu überwachen. Aber auch diese sehr fadenscheinige checks and balance, die da drinnen ist, ist eine Person, der darf der BVT auch noch die Auskunft verweigern, also sprich, der kann den Rechtsschutzbeauftragten umgehen, wenn er Gefahr im Vorzug sieht oder eine Gefahr für die öffentliche Sicherheit sieht. Das heißt, die einzige Kontrolle, die es für diese Behörde gibt, kann sie selber auch noch umgehen aufgrund ihrer eigenen Meinung.
Wie kommt man denn auf sowas? Hattet ihr irgendwie einen Terroranschlag, den ich nicht mitbekommen habe? Nein.
Natürlich Charlie Hebdo. Also Belgien, Paris und Dänemark sind da sicherlich auch nochmal ein Mitgrund gewesen. Unsere konservativen Innen- und Justizministerium trommeln auch ganz laut für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sind da aber bis jetzt nicht weit gekommen, weil die Sozialdemokraten an dem einen Punkt in Österreich bis jetzt diese Position halten und uns noch nicht verraten haben. Und ja, also das ganze Teil ist wirklich, wir sagen das auch wirklich als Acker Vorrat, das ist schlimmer als die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. In den wirklichen Auswüchsen, welche Art von Überwachungsmaschinerie man hier kreiert, die komplett unkontrolliert ist, die man ja auch als Regierung eigentlich nicht mehr einfangen kann, das nach Snowden zu etablieren, ohne irgendwas zu lernen aus der Geschichte, das geht einfach nicht. Wir haben uns deswegen als Acker Vorrat wirklich, als das Teil rausgekommen ist, sofort hingesetzt. Wir haben eine 79-seitige Stellungnahme geschrieben, im Begutachtungsverfahren. Drei Juristen von uns und ich sind da über eine Woche lang gesessen, nur um irgendwie alle Fehler in diesem Gesetz zu finden. Und wir listen da eben alle möglichen Unten-Dinger, die da drinnen stecken, wie eben auch so lustige Sachen, wie der Zweck für eine legitime Datenverarbeitung, also wieso du Daten angreifen kannst, kombinieren kannst, Rasterfahndung machen kannst. Der deckt sich eins zu eins mit der Aufgabenstellung des Bundesamtes zur Verfassungsschutz- und Terrorismusbekämpfung. Also solange irgendjemand da drinnen dienstlich arbeitet, ist Datenschutz scheißegal. Es gibt überhaupt keine Ausweitung von parlamentarischer Kontrolle, von Rechtsschutz oder von Transparenz. Es ist nicht mal eine Evaluierung vorgesehen. Auch in der Reform als Ziel ist jetzt nicht formuliert, dass man damit irgendwie die Aufklärungsquote steigern will. Sondern in der Evaluierung geht es einfach nur darum, ob die Budgetziele erreicht werden, also wie viel Geld man für die Überwachung ausgibt. Und das geht so dermaßen weit an allem vorbei, was in der Zeit gediegen wäre und was wir jetzt auch brauchen. Ich meine, das macht uns ja auch alle nicht sicherer, wenn wir den Heuhaufen größer machen. Du hast das ja schon öfters in der Sendung angesprochen. Hier wird natürlich auch ganz massiv das Opportunitätsprinzip und das Legalitätsprinzip gebrochen, weil es hier eine Polizeibehörde gibt, die dich anklagen kann. Aber die hat annähernd geheimdienstliche Befugnisse. Weil allein die Beurteilung der Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem verfassungsgefährdenden Angriff reicht aus, um die komplette Palette an Überwachungsbefugnissen auszupacken. Und wir haben in Österreich genügend Fälle, wo die gegen Zivilgesellschaft, gegen Tierschützer eingesetzt wurden. Also es ist bei weitem nicht so, als wenn wir jetzt irgendwie großes Vertrauen in unsere Polizeibehörden oder unser Justizsystem hätten. Das sind die Leute, denen man diese Instrumente in die Hand gibt.
Ich finde das auch irgendwie ein verfassungsgefährdender Angriff. Ja, also ich meine, Mohammed, na doch hat er. Aber okay, also was ist denn ein verfassungsgefährdender Angriff? Das ist ja wirklich mal eine irre Formulierung, weil ich jetzt gerade so überlege, so... Ich glaube in Deutschland wäre der Begriff eher verfassungsfeindlich?
Ja, ja, das ist vielleicht die Analogie dazu. Aber es hat sich nämlich auch der Aufgabenbereich der Behörde geändert mit dieser Reform. Davor war das eben der Schutz der Verfassung. Das umfasst eben auch unsere aller Grundrechte und die demokratische Grundordnung. In Zukunft ist die Ausgabe dieser Behörde nur noch der Schutz des Staates und seiner Funktionsfähigkeit. Also hier ist auch die Bevölkerung und ihre Grundrechte auch schon nicht einmal mehr auf dem Papier das, worum es geht. Das stinkt einfach so dermaßen nach Orwell. Und mettern nicht 2.0. Wir sind hier wirklich eigentlich in höchstem Aufruhr. Wir versuchen massivst im laufenden Begutachtungsverfahren von allen Seiten darauf aufmerksam zu machen, was hier in diesem Gesetz drinnen steht. Und wir würden uns auch da freuen, wenn möglichst viele Leute irgendwie mal unsere Stellungnahme lesen. Wir bringen auch bald nochmal ein Handout raus, dass man sich nicht durch 79 Seiten durchlesen muss. Und das Begutachtungsverfahren ist sozusagen der Zeitraum, in dem man sich mit einer Stellungnahme äußern kann. Und das kann jeder machen. Jede Organisation, aber auch jede Privatperson. Das läuft noch bis zum 12. Und das ist sozusagen die erste Linie, wo man jetzt noch mal irgendwie schauen kann, dass möglichst viele Leute da mal den Finger draufhalten. Weil das Ganze soll noch vor der Sommerpause beschlossen werden. Also sprich, ich glaube, 2. oder 7. Juli ist die letzte Plenumsitzung unseres Nationalrats. Und dann könnte das Ganze schon beschlossen werden, also im Eilverfahren, sodass es ab 1. Jänner 2016 schon in Kraft ist. Und ja, das ist mehr oder weniger, was ich die letzten Wochen gemacht habe. Und wir hoffen natürlich, dass es hier noch massive Aufmerksamkeit gibt, weil das darf einfach so in dieser Form nicht durchgehen. Wir finden sowieso das ganze Gesetz muss zurück an den Start. Hier fehlt nämlich auch schon mal irgendwie die Evaluierung am Anfang, dass man sagt, okay, wo drückt überhaupt der Schuh, wo fehlen Kompetenzen? Und nicht irgendwie einen Blankoscheck ausstellen. Und da müsste man hier viel gezielter vorgehen mit Augenmaß. Da müsste man auch Zahlen vorlegen. Hier werden auch teilweise Maßnahmen, die sich angeblich bewährt haben, da wird der Bedarf an Rechtsschutz oder an z.B. dringenden Verdachte gegeben sein muss für eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, wird einfach weggestrichen. Und das ist komplett der falsche Weg, weil da werden wahnsinnige Doppelgleisigkeiten geschaffen. Und jeder Beamte in dieser Behörde kann einfach nur mit der Zeit ein Gottkomplex bekommen, weil er sich halt einfach wirklich an nichts mehr halten muss, außer an irgendwelche internen Vorgaben.
Krass. Ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen, die 79 Seiten sind nicht der Gesetzesentwurf, sondern eure Stellungnahmen.
Wir haben also von den 79 Seiten, da ist auch, wir haben eine Excel-Tabelle noch gemacht, wo wir genau auflisten, welche Straftatbestände dann auf einmal zum verfassungsgefährdenden Angriff werden und wie sich die Überwachungsbefugnisse da ändern. Also, dass du dann zum Beispiel für großen, kleinen Lauschangriff noch einen Richter brauchst oder keinen mehr oder Staatsanwalt oder eben nur noch diesen Rechtsschutzbeauftragten. Damit das eben auch möglichst verständlich ist. Da haben wirklich viele Juristen dran gearbeitet, aber wir versuchen es allgemein verständlich zu machen. Und bald kommt hoffentlich noch mal so ein Handout, dass das Ganze noch mal prägnant und mit Infografiken verständlich macht. Weil wir haben halt im Moment irgendwie so ein Vermittlungsproblem. Das Ding war irgendwie in der ersten Woche, nachdem es draußen war, groß in den Medien. Es gab auch nur Kritik. Aber die Regierung ist da halt einfach unbeirrbar. Man muss jetzt einfach genügend Druck aufbauen, sodass sich die Sozialdemokraten, die SPÖ, das vielleicht noch mal überlegt, ob sie da jetzt wirklich zustimmen will.
Noch mal kurz die Frage. Ich kenne das von Gesetzesentwürfen so. Okay, klar, das riecht jetzt eher nach sowas, was man irgendwie schnell durchpeitschen und verstecken möchte. Aber ich kenne das häufig so, dass zumindest in dem Gesetzesentwurf dann irgendwie so kurz drinsteht, was das denn jetzt soll. Also welches Problem meinen Sie denn damit zu lösen? Also ist es jetzt gerade mal wieder an der Zeit?
Es fehlen leider alle möglichen Zahlen, die man sich wünschen würde, anhand denen man festmachen könnte, wieso jetzt hier gerade in dem Bereich Kompetenzen ausgeweitet werden. Also die konkreten Maßnahmen sind überhaupt nicht begründet. Natürlich ist der Hintergrund eine Mischung von Foreign Fighters, islamischer Staat kombiniert mit den jüngsten Terroranschlägen in Europa. Das ist sozusagen der politische Hintergrund, vor dem die Law-and-Order-Fraktion eben gerade trommelt und dieses Gesetz durchbringen will. Es fehlt ein Steckholterprozess, es fehlt eine öffentliche Diskussion. Wie gesagt, es gab einen parlamentarischen Prozess, aber der wurde einfach vor dem Ende abgebrochen und dann wurde etwas als Gesetz vorgelegt, was nichts damit zu tun hatte. Das kam für alle mehr oder weniger aus dem Nichts. Wir haben nichts Gutes vermutet, aber dass da so viel Schlechtes drin steht, hat uns doch sehr gewundert. Eine wirkliche Begründung natürlich öffentliche Sicherheit. Angst vor Terror, wir müssen jetzt etwas tun, ganz dringend. Das sind die offiziellen Begründungen. Das hat aber natürlich nichts mit der Realität zu tun, weil das müsste man hier mit Augenmaß machen und nicht einfach einen Blankoscheck ausstellen. Das Problem ist, dass in der Bevölkerung natürlich dieses Bewusstsein da ist. Ja, aber es ist doch so schlimm und wir haben doch diese Terrorangst, die hier gerade auch durch den Boulevard geschürt wird. Und dass man dem aber nicht beikommt, indem man eine allmächtige Behörde macht, die niemandem verantwortlich ist. Das ist halt irgendwie der kognitiver Schritt, der vielleicht dem Boulevard nicht gemacht wird. Und dem muss man jetzt unterbringen, dass das hier einfach ein massives Missbrauchspotenzial hat. Und in Österreich ist es leider so, dass Behörden oft in einer gewissen Selbstherrlichkeit, die vom Duktus her eher noch in die K&K-Monarchie passen würde, sich einfach Dinge leisten, die schon auf den bestehenden Gesetzen nicht mehr ganz klar einzuordnen sind. Und mit solchen Kompetenzen sehen wir einfach, dass der Boden der Verfassung komplett verlassen wird. Und deswegen gilt es jetzt mal, solange dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahren noch läuft, das irgendwie möglichst früh zu stoppen. Und je früher wir jetzt viel Aufmerksamkeit darauf lenken können, und je mehr Leute verstehen, was hier überhaupt in diesem Gesetz drinnen ist. Weil ich glaube, das ist der Schlüssel. Wenn einfach mal den Leuten klargemacht wird, wie unbackbar das ist, was da drinnen steht, dann glaube ich, dass wir schon an vielen Stellen die Öffentlichkeit auf unserer Seite haben. Wir versuchen im Moment, vor allem viele Stellungnahmen von anderen Institutionen in Österreich, die viel Gewicht haben, zu bekommen. Dass einfach klar ist, unsere Bedenken werden geteilt. Wir sind nicht nur eine kleine netzpolitische NGO, sondern wir sind wirklich auch hier an dieser Stelle die Speerspitze von einer größeren Bewegung. Deswegen haben wir uns auch so beeilt damit.
Aber Thomas, hast du denn vielleicht auch irgendeine gute Nachricht mitgebracht? Also ich meine, wir haben bis jetzt...
Zu dem Teil her, in den Show notes findet ihr alles, was ihr braucht, um eine Stellungnahme abzugeben für das Gesetz. Das kann jeder machen und jeder machen. Und bei Rückfragen gerne an Info- oder AK-Vorrader-Team. Und mal schauen, wie das ausgehen wird. Das werden wir sehen, wie gesagt, vielleicht noch vor der Sommerpause wird da der Groschen schon fallen. Aber ich habe auch wirklich, wirklich gute Nachrichten mitgebracht. Das ist jetzt irgendwie ein harter Schnitt. Aber Netzneutralität, das Thema meines Herzens. Da hat sich was wirklich Schönes getan. Nicht nur in den USA ist das Thema jetzt irgendwie durch, weil die FCC, die amerikanische Regulierungsbehörde, sich da ja für wirklich gute Regeln durchgesetzt hat, die leider gerade angegriffen werden von den Konservativen. Die Republikaner versuchen das gerade alles irgendwie so im Kongress niederzurengen, aber das ist noch nicht durch. Auf jeden Fall in den USA haben wir jetzt mal eine starke Bewegung für Netzneutralität und das sieht so aus, als wenn die gerade nach Indien überschwappt. In Indien gab es nämlich einen ähnlichen Vorstoß. Da hat nämlich die dortige Regulierungsbehörde in Indien Regeln vorgelegt, die auch Netzneutralität abgeschafft hätten. So ähnlich wie das die FCC ja Anfang letzten Jahres auch vorhatte. Und damit diese Regeln nicht unwidersprochen sind, hat sich dann eine Comedy-Truppe von Indern mit einem YouTube-Video zu Wort gemeldet. Und das Thema Netzneutralität wahnsinnig schön und wahnsinnig lustig auf den Punkt gebracht. Das erinnert sehr an das legendäre John Oliver Video zu diesem Thema. Und die haben es geschafft, innerhalb von kürzester Zeit eine Million Mails an die indische Regulierungsbehörde zu schicken. Und die sind jetzt gerade irgendwie in Schockstarre. Es haben sich auch schon mehrere Parteien in Indien zu dem Thema geäußert und sind auf einmal für Netzneutralität. Also da ist gerade wirklich so ein Meinungsumschwenk in der Bevölkerung in Indien und in der Politik für Netzneutralität. Und das Bemerkenswerte daran ist, dass es hier eben auch ganz klar um Zero-Rating geht. Also um Preisdiskriminierung, ökonomische Diskriminierung. Wir wissen ja, du kannst Netzneutralität auf zwei Arten verletzen, auf einer technischen Ebene, indem du manche Datenpakete schneller behandelt oder schneller überträgst als andere. Und eben auch ökonomisch, sprich du hast manche Datenpakete, die teurer sind als andere oder die von deinem monatlichen Volumen abgezogen werden oder eben nicht. Und genau dieses Zero-Rating ist im Kern der aktuellen Debatte in Indien. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass internet.org extrem unter Bedrängnis geraten ist in Indien und sogar schon einige erste Provider dort sich von dieser Plattform verabschiedet haben. Zur Erinnerung, internet.org ist dieses Pet-Project von Mark Zuckerberg, das ist ähnlich wie Facebook Zero, ein Projekt, in dem in Entwicklungsländern, in Ländern mit unterentwickeltem Telekommunikationsmarkt, gratis Zugang zu manchen Diensten des Internets angeboten wird. Sprich, Leute, die Telefon haben, SIM-Rate haben, damit vielleicht auch telefonieren können, aber kein Internet haben, die können über internet.org Facebook nutzen, Wikipedia nutzen und noch ein paar Seiten, Jobplattformen, Infoseiten über Molaria usw. Und dieses internet.org tarnen sich so ein bisschen als Charity, da geht es darum, dass Leute Zugang zum Internet bekommen, das erste Mal. Aber in Wirklichkeit geht es Facebook natürlich darum, neue Kunden zu gewinnen und mehr Menschen ins Netz zu bekommen, vor allem in ihren Dienst zu bekommen, sie dazu zu zwingen, ihre Kunden zu werden, de facto. Und gerade dieses internet.org wird gerade aus Indien, von ganz vielen Stimmen, aus dem globalen Süden kritisiert als ökonomischer Rassismus, als Patronising. Und diese Debatte, die haben wir sehr gebraucht, dass es da wirklich aus dem Süden Stimmen gibt. Es gab vor allem in Europa schon NGOs, die sich dazu kritisch geäußert haben, wie Access Now, wie die Initiative für Netzfreiheit in Österreich. Und das ist aber wahnsinnig wichtig, dass das wirklich aus der dortigen Bevölkerung kommt und dort kritisch gesehen wird. Und für internet.org ist das auf jeden Fall mal ein harter Schlag, weil sie jetzt eben wirklich mal ins Zentrum der Debatte gerückt werden und endlich auch die ganzen Abhängigkeiten, die über solche Zero-Rating-Angebote in den Entwicklungsländern geschaffen werden, mal durchleuchtet werden. Das ist nämlich immer der Pferdefuß. Das hört sich im ersten Moment so toll an. Menschen, die noch nicht im Internet sind, bekommen auf einmal Zugang zu manchen Seiten. Aber dass man damit halt eigentlich nur den eigenen Markt vergrößert, neue Abhängigkeiten schafft, das wird oft nicht dazu gesagt. Und das sind halt eben so langfristige Konsequenzen, die man hier ganz klar mit im Blick haben muss. Und was in Indien gerade passiert, ist wahnsinnig spannend und sollte man auf jeden Fall im Blick behalten.
Also in Indien hast du aber natürlich auch ein Land, die haben, glaube ich, sogar noch, die haben, die Alphabetisierung ist da noch nicht besonders weit vorangeschritten. Du hast 1,3 Milliarden Einwohner dort, die alle möglichen verschiedenen Sprachen sprechen. Du hast schockierende Armut in großen, weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung. Und natürlich so ein, vor allem hat dieser Staat Schwierigkeiten, diese große Mengen an Bevölkerung mit Bildung zu versehen. Insofern so eine Wikipedia Zero Geschichte hätte aber, du weißt, ich bin ja immer der Advokatus, die Aruli, unter Umständen das Potenzial, der Entwicklung der Gesellschaft starken Vorschub zu leisten. Und man könnte jetzt bösartig argumentieren, okay, dann werden sie halt Facebook-Kunden. Wenigstens müssen sie sich nicht arm machen, wenn sie irgendwie mit dem Internet in Verbindung treten wollen. Wobei ja ganz andere Probleme da komplett außen vor gelassen werden, nämlich woher sollen diese Menschen, wenn sie sich die Minuten nicht leisten können oder die Datenpakete nicht leisten können, woher wollen sie dann eben internetfähige Endgeräte bekommen, die ja auch mit einem hohen Preis verbunden sind und die auch in Indien bei weitem nicht für jeden erschwinglich sind. Also bei weitem nicht. Und dann will ich aber noch kurz anmerken, diejenigen, die da protestieren, das sind ja aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht die, die unterprivilegierten Nutzer, die jetzt irgendwie sagen, nee, dann wollen wir lieber gar kein Internet. Also ich denke, das ist ja auch die Falle dieser Internet.org-Kampagne, oder nicht?
Ja, also du hast bei Wikipedia Zero halt ein Abgrenzungsproblem. Wir alle finden irgendwie Wikipedia toll, trotz mancher Kritik ist es immer noch ein extrem unterstützenswertes Projekt. Und natürlich ist es wunderbar, wenn mehr Menschen Zugriff dazu haben, vor allem wenn sonst die Alternative überhaupt keinen Zugriff auf irgendein Wissen hat, ist aus dem Internet. Und ich glaube auch, dass die harte Problematik dann über Feature Phones, die ja oft irgendwie einen extrem langen Lebenszyklus haben, doch abgefedert werden kann. Das Grundproblem bleibt aber an der Stelle, dass du damit halt einfach neue Abhängigkeiten schaffst. Es mag so sein, dass du kurzfristig da mehr Leute mit Zugang versorgst, aber die Vorstellung, die die Leute dort von dem Internet haben werden, ist einfach, dass Facebook das Internet ist. Und da gibt es inzwischen jetzt auch schon Studien aus Pakistan und Indien, dass über 50 Prozent der Leute, der Auslager zustimmen, dass Facebook das Internet ist. Und du hast halt einfach immer diese zwei Seiten. Dass es hier auch vor allem um eine Dominanz in der Marktposition geht, um die nächste Milliarde Nutzer, die man in den eigenen Dienst holen will. Und ganz wichtig ist auch zu bedenken, gerade im Fall von Facebook, die Leute bezahlen ja eigentlich schon für ihren Netzzugang mit ihren Daten. Nur anstelle echtes Internet bekommen sie halt eben nur Facebook. Und hier wird halt auch von einem amerikanischen westlichen Konzern diktiert, was diese Leute an Diensten nutzen können. Das ist der schwerste Schlag für jede Art von lokalen Start-up, den du mir vorstellen kannst. Deswegen sind es ja eben auch gerade, wie du sagst, es sind gerade für Stimmen aus der indischen Wirtschaft, vor allem auch der Tech-Szene, die sagen, wir wollen das nicht. Das ist genau eine neue Art von digitalen Kolonialismus, die wir nicht haben wollen, weil es genau in die falsche Richtung geht. Und wir glauben eigentlich, dass wir ein lokales Potenzial haben, die nächsten Facebooks hier für uns zu entwickeln. Aber gerade in Bezug auf sozialen Netzwerken, wo die Pfadabhängigkeit ja wahnsinnig groß ist, wenn du und deine Freunde und jeden, den du kennst, mal in einem sozialen Netzwerk ist, ist es schwierig davon wegzuwechseln. Also auch diese Möglichkeit, hier irgendwie Alternativen zu entwickeln, wird komplett verwehrt und unmöglich gemacht mit solchen Deals. Ich sage jetzt auch nicht, dass im spezifischen Kontext von Entwicklungsländern jede Art von Zero-Rating-Angebot schlecht sein muss. Aber man muss wirklich genau hinschauen. Stell dir vor Ebola-Gebiete. Und du hast dort dann Zugriff auf gewisse Notfallinformationen, auf Wikipedia, um Symptome nachzuschlagen, egal was es ist. Und das ist mal für alle zumindest netzeitig möglich. Sobald du irgendwas hast, was mit dem Netz redet, kannst du dieses und jenes Informationsangebot nutzen.
Da brauchst du halt deinen Marktzuckerband nicht für. Das kannst du von Seiten des Telefonproviders freundlich zur Verfügung stellen.
Ja, oder UNHCR und so. Ich meine, ein riesiges Feld. Das hat man ja in der Auswertung der Telekommunikationsdaten in Ebola gesehen, um da epidemiologische Vorhersagen zu machen. Aber mein Kernpunkt ist, gerade in Afrika ist diese Debatte noch mal weiters zugespitzt da. Da gehe ich auch auf meinem Republikatalk noch mal mehr ein. Aber da hast du ja noch dazu die Situation, dass es ganz wenig lokale Infrastruktur gibt und dass inzwischen immer mehr Dronen und Zeppelline verwendet werden, um in extrem ländlichen Gebieten Infrastruktur zu projizieren. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass du diese Infrastruktur nach den 100 Tagen, die so eine Drohne durchschnittlich in der Luft bleibt, auch wieder abziehen kannst. Das heißt, hier wird auch überhaupt keine nachhaltige lokale Investition getätigt, sondern hier ist diese Abhängigkeit, die wir sonst irgendwie auf dem Informationslevel haben, wirklich auch noch mal auf dem Hardware-Netzlevel gegeben. Und ich finde halt auch, man kann sich überlegen, dass man irgendwie Dinge finanziert über Zero-Rating-Angebote, aber immer nur mit einer zeitlichen Begrenzung und auch immer nur mit höchster Transparenz dann auch wirklich über die Verträge, die hier geschlossen werden. Das ist ein großes Thema. Aber jetzt mal hier in Indien, glaube ich, ist es wahnsinnig wichtig, dass es überhaupt mal diese Gegenbewegung gibt. Und ich würde schon meinen, dass es da, wenn man sich wirklich auf einer politischen Ebene trifft und Konzepte entwickelt, wie man denn diese hundert Millionen Menschen auf jeden Fall in einen ordentlichen Internetzugang bringt, dann findet man weitaus bessere Möglichkeiten als die Idee von Mark Zuckerberg mit internet.org.
Na du hast, also es gibt gerade in diesen Ländern Afrika und einigen asiatischen Ländern, wo eben die Internetisierung der Bevölkerung noch nicht so fortgeschritten ist. Da sitzen natürlich Leute und machen sich Gedanken darüber. Und vor allem sitzen da Leute, die sich auch Gedanken darüber machen, dass sie nicht in die Fallen laufen wollen, in die andere Firmen gerannt sind. Also wenn du dir das heute anschaust, blickst du jetzt als reicher Mensch in Indien und dann siehst du, hier ist ein riesiger Markt, weil wir viele hundert Millionen Menschen haben, die kein Internetzugang haben. Die werden den früher oder später haben wollen. Und dann kann man mit denen Geld verdienen. Und da müssen jetzt Investitionen getätigt werden. Dann lehnt es sich aber natürlich auch zurück und du sagst, wie wird denn jetzt gerade im Internet Geld verdient? Und wie nicht? Und da möchte natürlich zum Beispiel keiner das Problem haben, über das jetzt irgendwie deutsche Internet-Provider zum Beispiel klagen, dass sie sagen, hey, wir haben hier das ganze Kupfer vergraben, auch wenn wir eigentlich Glasfaser hätten verlegen sollen. Aber wir bringen den Leuten das Internet und die Leute hängen den ganzen Tag da dran und gucken Netflix und gucken YouTube und hören Spotify und gucken sich Werbeanzeigen bei Facebook an. Und alles, was wir bekommen, sind irgendwie läppische 30 Euro oder was im Monat. Und da gibt es natürlich viele, die sich darüber Gedanken machen und sagen, ok, da gibt es natürlich einen Mark Zuckerberg, der sagt, naja, wenn die alle dazu kommen, die sollen bitte alle schön auch zu Facebook kommen. Da gibt es genug andere, die sagen, naja, wie du auch gerade schon ansprachst, da wollen wir halt zusehen, dass wir ein eigenes Facebook bauen, damit das Geld nicht der Mark Zuckerberg kriegt und seine Aktionäre, sondern vielleicht wir ein bisschen von dem Geld in unserem Land lassen können. Aber da gibt es natürlich auch in der Wirtschaft ein Interesse, in anderen Formen die Netzneutralität vielleicht zu verletzen, oder Zero-Rating-Angebote zu machen und so. Also das ist, ich glaube, jeder, der da heute auf der einen oder auf der anderen Seite steht als wirtschaftlicher Akteur, hat da auf jeden Fall noch mal eigene Interessen mit im Spiel. Aber natürlich ist es sehr positiv zu bewerten, dass die Zivilbevölkerung sich jetzt noch relativ früh, also wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie viele Leute da noch ans Internet angeschlossen werden können, wenn die Zivilgesellschaft sich da jetzt schon so früh so starkes Gehör verschafft. Das ist schon eine sehr feine Sache. Und da kann man hoffen, dass die sich auch durchsetzen werden. Denn auf jeden Fall unterliegen die da sehr, sehr starken ökonomischen Interessen, die Internetnutzer. Also das ist noch so ein richtig fetter Wachstumsmarkt im Vergleich zu Europa, wo jetzt aus so einem Plateau erreicht ist, dass ich jetzt, obwohl ich nur ein iPhone 5 habe, keinerlei starken Anfeindungen und Ausgrenzungen meiner Altersgenossen ausgesetzt bin. Und dadurch natürlich dieser ganze Markt so ein bisschen langsam, ich sage jetzt mal, nicht zum Erliegen kommt, aber der ist jetzt halt so langsam gesättigt. Diese Entwicklung hat jetzt ihre rasanten Wachstumsphasen hinter sich. Und in vielen Ländern stehen die eben noch bevor. Und da gibt es starke Interessen, dass sie da nicht so verlaufen, wie sie halt in Europa und in den USA verlaufen sind.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist eines der Themen, die mich persönlich am meisten interessieren zurzeit, wie sich dort das Netz entwickelt. Weil das ist eine enorm große Frage für Wirtschaftsentwicklung, Entwicklungszusammenarbeit. Und ich fand die Analogie, die du vorher gebracht hast, das ist schon sicherlich genau die Überlegung, die manche Firmen dort haben. Wie finanzieren wir das denn? Aber wenn du dieser Logik folgst, sozusagen, ja, ich muss irgendwie mehr Geld aus meinem Netz schlagen, damit ich wieder in mein Netz investieren kann. Beziehungsweise ich will ja ein Unternehmen und ich will immer irgendwie mehr Geld verdienen, egal ob ich jetzt wirklich in mein Netz investiere, aber das ist ein super Argument vor der Politik. Und ich sehe, dass hier andere Leute Geld über meine Leitungen mit meinen Kunden verdienen. Ich will irgendwie ein Stück von deren Kuchen. Vertikale Integration entlang der Wertschöpfungskette. Der verdammte Grund, wieso wir überhaupt eine Netzvertralitätsdebatte haben in Wirklichkeit. Und wenn du dieser Logik folgst und das dann aber wieder aufs analoge anwendest, ist es überhaupt legitim, mit einem Netz Geld zu verdienen, das wirklich als Cash Cow zu betreiben. Wäre es okay gewesen, wenn wir irgendwie die Straßenbetreiber, wären die damals privatisiert gewesen, von den Umsatzsteigerungen, die auf einmal über gesteigerte Mobilität möglich wären, beteiligt hätten, hätte uns das in die richtige Richtung geführt. In Wirklichkeit ist schon auch ein bisschen so die Debatte darum, wem gehört eigentlich das Netz und wollen wir, dass das hier eine Infrastruktur ist, die in Form von Aktienhandel eine Geldanlage ist, die kurzfristig viel Geld bringen soll, oder ist das nicht eher etwas, das für die Daseinsvorsorge eines Staates gehört? Insofern, ich habe das ja in den Kommentaren zu der vorverletzten Sendung schon mal erwähnt, bin ich es extrem bezeichnet, dass die USA, also die FCC da, die Regeln zur Netzvertralität verabschiedet hat, sie auch ihren Ben und Community Fiber, also ihre Blockade, was Kommunen Glasfasernetze angeht, aufgehoben haben. Weil in Wirklichkeit geht das ultimativ Hand in Hand, wenn du es dir zu Ende denkst. Und man kann sich immer irgendwie lokale Modelle überlegen, wie man vor allem Investitionen querfinanziert in Situationen, wo es einfach keinen Markt gibt, der oder keine Investitionsbedingungen, die mir erlauben, dass ein Unternehmen sich einfach über normale Wege Geld für Infrastrukturinvestitionen besorgen kann. Aber ganz wichtig ist bei all diesen Debatten immer, die langfristige Komponente und die Abhängigkeit mit zu bedenken. Und vor allem, wenn ich auf einer Informations-, auf einer Plattform-Ebene hier eine gewisse Hegemonie und ich finde schon auch einen Konditionalismus mitbringe, mit dem die Leute zum ersten Mal in das Netz kommen, dann führt das wirklich auch nicht in eine Situation, wo du da ein autarkes Netz haben wirst. Und vor allem, wo du auch in der Bevölkerung dieses Bewusstsein schaffst, was das Internet eigentlich für eine Erfindung ist, was damit möglich ist. Und wenn man irgendwas gesehen hat aus diesen ganzen One Laptop per Child-Dingern, dass es doch eigentlich genügend Beispiele gibt, dass wir überrascht sind von der Kreativität von Leuten, wenn sie dann irgendwann einmal mit echtem Internet verbunden sind. Ich glaube nicht, dass man so eine Kreativität auf einer Facebook-Only-Plattform erleben wird.
Nein, nein, ich wollte auch nicht sagen, dass das jetzt irgendwie eine wünschenswerte Entwicklung ist. Aber ich denke, man muss schon auf diese Bedingungen dieses Marktes hinweisen. Ich finde es sehr schön, dass du diese One Laptop per Child als Beispiel nennst. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Menschen auf der Welt, die nie zu dem Internet, wie wir es kennen, Kontakt hatten. Und vor allem, die, wenn sie jetzt dann dieses Internet bekommen, das auch nicht mit einem Computer erfahren werden, sondern die werden das Internet als Smartphone-Feature kennenlernen. Und das ist einfach noch eine interessante Entwicklung, die da stattfindet. Aber ich glaube, wir haben auch zumindest zur Netzneutralität in Indien jetzt viel gesagt. Es gibt aber auch noch eine Netzneutralität in Europa zu retten. Erzähl mir da doch noch mal schnell was von.
Ja, im Grunde fast das Wichtigste zuletzt. Kommen wir vom Globalen nach Europa. Was ist denn da Status quo? Wir haben jetzt irgendwie in den USA, in Brasilien, in Kanada, in den Nilen und in Stovenien eigentlich irrsinnig gute Gesetze zur Netzneutralität. Und in Europa schaut es so aus, als wenn wir genau in die falsche Richtung, in die andere Richtung marschieren. Es ist ja so, das Europaparlament hat sich im April 2014 dank der SaveTheInternet-Kampagne und der vielen tausenden Menschen, die da ihre Stimme erhoben haben, sich für Netzneutralität ausgesprochen. Und dann ist der Rat sehr lange in Verhandlungen gewesen und hat eine Position adaptiert, die leider genau das Gegenteil von Netzneutralität ist und noch dazu Netzsperren und Jugendschutzfilter mit sich bringt. Und jetzt sind wir im sogenannten Trilog. Also in der letzten Phase, bevor ein EU-Gesetz fertig wird und beschlossen wird. Da verhandeln die drei EU-Institutionen miteinander. Und der läuft jetzt schon seit 11. März. Und es gab auch schon die ersten zwei Sitzungen. Die letzte war letzte Woche am 21. April. Und die Verhandlungssituation ist im Moment so, dass sich eigentlich nicht wirklich viel bewegt. Der Rat vor allem versucht irgendwie auf seiner Position zu beharren und in überhaupt keine Richtung zu gehen. Die Kommission hat sich jetzt gerade irgendwie der Position des Rates angenähert. Also noch ein Stückchen weiter weg von Netzneutralität. Und in Richtung Netzsperren. Und das Parlament ist halt noch so in so einer Abwarteposition. Man hat da jetzt natürlich auch die verschiedenen Parteien, die Fraktionen, die irgendwie austarieren, was jetzt genau die Position ist. Das ist alles natürlich extrem intransparent. Und auch wenn man da Einblick in die Texte hat, ist es irrsinnig defizit, weil es ein verdammt kleiner Kreis an Menschen ist, der da am Ende verhandelt. Also in den großen Treffen sitzen 40 Leute, und im Europaparlament sind das irgendwie so 7 Leute mit jeweils noch irgendwie ein, zwei Assistenten, wenn es hochkommt und alle überhaupt zu den Treffen kommen. Das Europaparlament ist aber eigentlich unsere letzte Hoffnung in diesen Verhandlungen, weil wir wissen, dass im Rat definitiv keine gute Position das Ziel ist. Die Verhandlungen gehen dort eher in die andere Richtung. Und auch in der Kommission dank Günther Oettinger unter anderem, wissen wir, dass Netzvertralität eher was ist, das auf der Abschlussliste steht. Und deswegen ist das Europaparlament wieder mal unsere letzte Hoffnung. Und genau deswegen haben wir jetzt vor ein, zwei Wochen eine neue Iteration von SaveTheInternet.eu gestartet, auf der man sich informieren kann über den aktuellen Verhandlungsstand, über den Zeitplan und vor allem eben auch Kontakt aufnehmen kann mit den eigenen Europaabgeordneten. Wir haben wieder das beliebte FaxTool. Wir haben die Möglichkeit, Europaabgeordnete anzurufen, ihnen eine Mail zu schicken und diesmal auch einen Tweet. Und auch Facebook haben wir verlinkt, also möglichst viel auch öffentlich Druck zu machen. Im Moment ist das Ganze halt noch in der Situation, dass dieser kleine Kreis an Leuten wirklich verhandelt. Und wir können noch nicht genau sagen, wann das Ganze erstmal im federführenden Ausschuss und dann später noch im Plenum verabschiedet wird. Da ist es vor allem so, dass man ja eigentlich nur über den Kompromiss, der davor verhandelt wurde, zu- oder abstimmen kann. Also sprich, da kann man nur noch Ja und Nein sagen. Ähnlich wie bei einem Freihandelsabkommen. Aber es ist jetzt sozusagen wirklich mal im kleinen Kreis die Frage, ob man zu einem sinnvollen Text kommen wird. Und das ist sehr spannend, weil es wirklich noch nicht abzusehen ist. Aber das Ganze kann jetzt irrsinnig schnell gehen, wenn man sich einigt. Und wir sind auch wirklich nur noch einige letzte Schritte davon entfernt, dass wir eine Verordnung bekommen. Das heißt, ein Gesetz, was das Thema Netzeutralität mal irgendwie für die halbe Milliarde Menschen auf diesem Kontinent auf absehbare Zeit beantworten wird. Ja, und natürlich vor dem Hintergrund der globalen Entwicklung ist es desaströs, dass wir irgendwie sehen, die USA, Kanada, jetzt auch Indien, alle entscheiden sich irgendwie, Netzeutralität festzuschreiben, was natürlich auch wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche Konsequenzen hat. Und europäische Start-up wird es eher schwer haben, irgendwie international oder auch nur europäisch Fuß zu fassen, wenn es keine Netzeutralität mehr gibt. Die gesellschaftlichen Konsequenzen davon, dass wir ein Internet für Arme und Reiche bekommen, sind auch hinlänglich bekannt. Und wir haben hier wirklich die Gefahr, dass wir ins Hintertreffen geraten. Dass man da trotzdem auf Ebene der 28 EU-Mitgliedstaaten so eine wirklich kurzsichtige Position beschlossen hat, ist nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar. Und genau deswegen brauchen wir halt wieder mal das Europaparlament.
Was können wir noch mit auf den Weg geben? Ich habe ja auch schon ein paar Faxe verschickt. Ich muss aber zugeben, ich habe da meistens doch den Standardtext verschickt. Aber man soll eigentlich lieber mal noch seinen eigenen dazu schreiben, ne?
Ja, wir arbeiten da dran. Wenn es irgendwie übrigens findige Python- oder JavaScript-Coder gibt, ich könnte Unterstützung gebrauchen, mehr oder weniger mache ich das fast allein. Aber wir haben da ein paar Ideen, wie man das Ganze leicht personalisiert machen kann und auch eben übersetzt in die jeweilige Sprache. Dazu bräuchten wir aber ein paar findige Coder, die uns da helfen. Weil es ist halt wirklich wichtig, dass das personalisierte Messages sind, die vor allem mit einem regionalen Bezug zum Abgeordneten kommen. Das ist eigentlich das Effizienteste. So Massenfaxe, das ist natürlich auch etwas, was aufregt, weil wir eigentlich die einzigen sind, die dieses Instrument zumindest in der Größenordnung nutzen. Aber eigentlich ist es wirklich da wichtiger, auf Qualität statt auf Quantität zu setzen. Das Sinnvollste und Effizienteste ist aber wirklich, das Python-Tool von Lagquadratödi-Net zu nutzen und einfach anzurufen. Mit einem Abgeordneten persönlich zu sprechen, bzw. mit den Assistenten, aber das sind in vielen Fällen diejenigen, die wirklich die Meinung bilden, ist auf jeden Fall der effizienteste Weg, die eigene Position unterzubringen. Wenn die einen anderen Menschen auf der Leitung haben, da hilft auch kein Spam-Filter und keine Filterlisten auf Twitter oder sonst irgendetwas, da müssen sie abnehmen. Und wir haben auch jetzt schon 5000 Faxe verschickt, was auch schon eine beträchtliche Anzahl ist. Die ganze Kampagne wurde schon auf fünf Sprachen übersetzt. Also Englisch haben wir gestartet, wir haben schon Deutsch, Polnisch, Französisch und Spanisch dazu bekommen, das alles wieder nur von Freiwilligen, weil SaveTheInternet ist übrigens genauso wie die indische Netzvertralitätskampagne, die auch savetheinternet.de heißt, komplett auf GitHub. Das heißt, jeder kann sich da irgendwie den Code anschauen. Auch die Software, die wir fürs Faxen verwenden, ist im Frontend dort verfügbar. Und das funktioniert wahnsinnig gut, sowas einfach mal transparent zu machen und den Leuten die Möglichkeit zu geben, da einfach mal Änderungen vorzuschlagen, Pull-Requests zu schicken. Wir haben da auch gute Readme's. Und wie gesagt, das letzte Mal hatten wir, glaube ich, sogar Albanisch als Übersetzung, obwohl die nicht mal Teil der EU sind. Also das motiviert Leute, auch wenn sie mitmachen können bei so einer Kampagne. Und ich werde auch nochmal viel mehr über das Thema erzählen und vor allem eben die globale Bewegung einordnen und die Hintergründe auf dem Republikervortrag, den ich am 6. Mai halte, zwischen 15 und 16 Uhr, auf der Stage 2. Und am Tag davor, auf dieser Side-Conference der MABB, werde ich auch auf einem Panel sitzen und davor eine kurze Keynote halten zum Thema der Zentralität.
Sehr schön. Dann haben wir es ja doch noch geschafft, am Ende so ein bisschen was Positives mitzuhalten. Sowieso einen kleinen Lichtblick. Das finde ich ganz gut, dass wir das geschafft haben.
Ja, nach dem negativen Einstieg, den wir heute hatten. Aber ich glaube, das ist ja schon irgendwie Trauerbewältigung, was Logbuch Netzpolitik hier eigentlich macht, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. Meistens macht es mir Spaß. Aber für heute hat es mir genug Spaß gemacht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin ein bisschen müde.
Wir haben gesagt, wir machen eine kurze Sendung, oder?
Das ist auch bei Tim immer schon so vorgarant. Also wenn ich am Anfang sage, mal gehen wir jetzt schnell durch, dann haben wir immer so epische Romane, die wir dann da erzählen. Aber es war mir eine große Freude mit dir. Du wolltest, glaube ich, noch etwas ankündigen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt schon irgendwie Leute dazu motiviert, Stellungnahmen im Begutachtungsverfahren zu schicken, Europaabgeordnete zu kontaktieren. Aber ich höre nicht auf, ich habe noch ein letztes Ding. Das ist jetzt wirklich nur für die Österreicher. Und zwar gibt es einen Internet Governance Forum in Österreich am 16. und 17. September. Und die URL dazu ist IGF-Austria.at. Dort gibt es ein Web-Formular, wo man Sessions einreichen kann. Themen, die man gerne behandeln müsste. Oder auch so Organisationspunkte, die man gerne dort behandelt hätte. Und es wäre sehr sinnvoll, wenn sich da Leute über dieses Web-Formular mal auslassen würden, über Dinge, die ihnen wichtig sind. Weil da steht zwar sehr groß Partizipation und Zivilgesellschaft drauf. Aber damit das dann auch drin ist, bräuchte es noch ein bisschen mehr Beteiligung.
Haben die ihre Webseite auch auf GitHub liegen?
Nee.
Weil denen müsste man mal beibringen, wie man sich ein SSL-Zertifikat für sein Hostname macht.
Ja, das ist lustig. Diese Webseite wird betrieben von der NIC.at, also die Organisation, die alle.at-Domains in Österreich verwaltet. Also ein Ort, wo man keinerlei technische Kompetenz vermuten würde.
Okay, damit haben wir es aber wirklich. Mir bleibt an dieser Stelle nur noch einmal sehr herzlich dem Ralf zu danken. Und ich möchte auch nochmal an dieser Stelle dem Jan Morgenstern danken, der bei der letzten Folge die Audiospur von Tim gerettet hat. Auch wenn es sich für viele so angehört hat, als hätte er die kaputt gemacht. Nein, das war die Rettung, denn Tim hat seine Aufnahme verkackt und brauchte dann professionelle Hilfe aus seinem Datensalat, den er sich da auf die Festplatte hat schreiben lassen, irgendwie nochmal was zu machen, worauf man wenigstens im Entfernten erkennen konnte, was er da ins Mikrofon gesäuselt hat. Und wir bitten das natürlich zu entschuldigen. Tim durfte ja auch heute, musste ja einmal nachsitzen jetzt, durfte in der Sendung nicht mitmachen. Und wir geloben Besserung und bedanken aber trotzdem herzlich dem Jan für die Hilfe. Und damit würde ich sagen, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.